façon qu'ils sont peut-être les
meilleurs adeptes de la mondialisation
c'est à dire que ils ont inventé les
routes de la drogue bien avant que les
entreprises ne découvrent les bienfaits
de la mondialisation on ne visualise pas
à quel point ça peut être compliqué de
se retrouver avec dans son garage une
montagne de billets de banque comme ça
il faut en faire quelque chose l'argent
sale devient très rapidement et très
facilement gris et puis blanc il suffit
de passer par quelques sociétés écrans
mais à côté de ça vous avez tout un
réseau de banques qui sont beaucoup plus
ouverte au cash à l'époque de la crise
de 2008 vous dit même que les banques
qui ont été beaucoup moins regardante
sur la provenance de cet argent qui
arrivaient pour renflouer les caisses ça
a été même dire nations unies on a
constaté que plusieurs dizaines de
milliards issus du trafic de stupéfiants
ont été absorbés par un certain nombre
de banques aux états unis qui d'ailleurs
ont été poursuivis en justice et ont
payé des amendes en conséquence
[Musique]
excellente soirée à toutes et à tous
décryptage débat analyse invités
bienvenue sur arte france pour deux
heures d'émission tout de suite les
titres de ce mardi 30 mars parlera
parlera pas à veille de conseil de
défense sanitaire si le monde médical et
l'opposition exhorte emmanuel macron à
agir face à la dégradation de la
situation le chef de l'état temporisé
souhaite agir en temps voulu le
président envers et contre tout élément
de réponse dans un instant alors que la
barre des 5000 patients en soins
critiques a été dépassé ce soir votre
votera pas le report des élections
régionales se pose avec la crise
sanitaire alors que l'exécutif doit
trancher sur le maintien du scrutin en
juin des responsables de la majorité
évoquent la possibilité de laisser
députés et sénateurs se prononcer sur la
question
le conseil scientifique lui renvoie la
balle au gouvernement
verdict jeudi
[Musique]
si paris est dans le flou londres sort
du brouillard le royaume uni pays
d'europe le plus endeuillé par le cor
navires us des confine progressivement
aucun mort du co vite 19 n'a été
enregistré outre manche dimanche une
première en six mois un des continents
qui s'accompagne d'une campagne
vaccinale efficace mais la question des
deuxième dose se pose à présent près de
deux millions huit cent mille morts dus
qu'aux vite 19 dans le monde dont plus
de 300 milles au brésil ses voisins
sud-américains en proie également à une
nouvelle vague inquiétante à l'entâme de
la semaine de pâques argentine chili
venezuela ou encore pérou enregistrent
des records de contamination illégale et
depuis l'automne dernier
généreux
[Musique]
suspense insoutenable beaucoup de voix
annonce une prise de parole pour demain
soir d'autres démantèlements aucun des
secours dans quinze jours à la veille
d'un nouveau conseil de défense
sanitaire à l'elysée une allocution
d'emmanuel macro est plus que jamais sur
toutes les lèvres le président de plus
en plus pressée par le monde médical
d'agir face à la flambée de kobe de 19
le cap des 5000 malades en soins
critiques a été franche et ce a été
franchie ce soir d'après santé publique
france à maria soulève une saison
estivale qui pourrait briser le moral
des français
dans la tente de la prise de parole des
manuels macron le pont ces scientifiques
met en garde si aucune mesure
supplémentaire n'est prise l'été 2000 21
ans ne sera pas similaire à celui de
l'année passée
il serait erroné de penser que l'état de
l'épidémie en juin 2021 sera
nécessairement identiques à ceux qui
l'étaient en juin 2020 l'intensité la
nature des mesures de contrôle mises en
oeuvre au cours des deux mois qui
viennent sont un élément clé pour
anticiper l'état de la pandémie en juin
2021 une circulation importante du virus
par rapport à l'année dernière
en cause notamment les variants qui ont
mis en grande difficulté les hôpitaux
leur service de réanimation désormais
dépassé le pic de la deuxième vague
selon le conseil scientifique de
nouvelles souches pourraient aussi faire
leur apparition
plusieurs médecins annoncent devoir
faire un tri des patients en
ile-de-france où la situation se dégrade
de jour en jour une ligne rouge absolue
selon le ministre de l'économie bruno le
maire l'offre des soins dans les
hôpitaux se voit également dégradé selon
le professeur gilles pialoux à la proche
du week-end de pâques le ministre de
l'intérieur annonce un durcissement des
contrôles des polices il s'agit
évidemment de pouvoir souligner
l'importance en attendant peut-être des
mesures prises par le gouvernement d'ici
le week-end de pâques de ce week end de
haut risque de partir de son territoire
et donc des contrôles qui seront encore
renforcer la mobilisation des policiers
des gendarmes et en même temps de
pouvoir évidemment continuer ces
contrôles intensifs dès jeudi sur les
péages dans les gares pour éviter que
les français aient effectivement ne
respectent pas la règle des 10 km
jusqu'à lundi-mardi
même si le conseil scientifique ne nie
pas les effets de la vaccination elle
semble trop faible pour imaginer un
était loin de l'hexagone
si le président n'exclut pas de
nouvelles mesures visant à faire reculer
l'épidémie
ils souhaitent analyser l'efficacité de
celle déjà mise en place
une temporisation qui n'est semble-t-il
pas vue d'un bon oeil par de nombreux
experts en attendant le conseil de
sécurité sanitaire ce mercredi 19
départements sont pour le moment soumis
à des restrictions sanitaires renforcés
elle parlera parlera pas confinement
strict ou pas fermeture des écoles ou
pas mesures prises à temps ou pas c'est
notre décryptage en direct ce soir
jean-pierre ternes amian radiologue
président de l'union régionale des
professionnels de santé des médecins
libéraux en de vernir rhône-alpes et
philippe froguel chercheur généticien
professeur à l'impérial collège de
londres et à l'université lille ii
bonsoir messieurs merci de répondre à
nos questions si de nouvelles mesures ne
sont pas mises en place rapidement le
coït 19 pourrait être plus présent cet
été que l'été dernier c'est ce qu'estime
aujourd'hui le conseil scientifique
jean-pierre interne à meilhan si les
médecins disent souvent je n'ai pas à
dire s'il faut confiné ou pas c'est une
décision politique
là on peut quand même dire que le corps
médical dans son ensemble depuis
quelques temps fait de la politique en
disant il faut confiné non c'est pas que
le corps médical fait on va dire de la
politique c'est qu'on a des patients à
prendre en charge et qu'actuellement on
sait plus faire parce que on a quasiment
plus de capacité de mutation de nos
patients auraient à la seule zone qui
reste dans notre région c'est l'eau
l'ouest on va dire clermont ferrand et
qu'on a plus on a un taux d'occupation
en ré à tous les leaders et à son plat
faut pas oublier qu'on est dans une case
où on a les lits qui sont occupées par
la chirurgie de rattrapage des épisodes
précédents et maintenant ça devient
majoritaire vendu kobe donc la seule
marge de manoeuvre qu'on a c'est ce
qu'on appelle les us et les unités de
soins continus qui sont des réanimations
de niveau un peu inférieur plutôt dans
les hôpitaux privés
et cela soit en des programmes la
totalité de la chirurgie est bien
évidemment ça a un impact pour la
population et à ce moment là encore un
tout petit peu de marge de manoeuvre
mais dans tous les cas cette marge de
manoeuvre
on en a on en a pas en pratique ce soir
sont en santé publique france 1 5000
patients en soins critiques c'est l'une
des infos de la soirée pierre jeantet en
amiante je donne la parole maintenant à
philippe froguel la une de libération ce
matin c'était il attend quoi
avec une photo des manuels macron il
attend quoi selon vous contre il est
malade à l'hôpital ligne rouge absolue
selon le ministre de l'économie bruno le
maire en ce matin moi j'ai l'impression
que le gouvernement a pas envie de
prendre de décisions contraignantes
sinon on l'aurait il aurait déjà fait je
suis pas sûr qu'ils qu'ils nous croient
nous les médecins quand on dit que ça va
s'aggraver il attend godot c'est à dire
que l'aimer et mesure qu il n'a pas
prise depuis un mois soit soit vraiment
efficace simplement s'agit pas de
modélisation on est un taux de
reproduction du virus qui est de 115% en
france donc on aura quinze pour cent de
plus de patients dans une semaine et on
aura d'autres 15% tu de personnes en
plus qui risquent de se retrouver en
aurait ni massa c'est pas des
modélisations sais c'est obligatoire
ensuite quand on se pose des questions
sur un peu long terme via un plus long
terme j'en sais rien ça va dépendre de
la rapidité la vaccination qui quand
même pas très très rapide en france pour
l'instant sans efficacité l'arrivée de
nouveaux variants ce que feront les
français qui ont été quand même très
très démobilisés parlent parlent le
breton la république qui à force de dire
c'est pas la peine de confiner on l'a vu
le week-end dernier à paris personne
était confiné ça c'est évident donc on a
de quoi être un petit peu pessimiste et
quant à ce que fera le président opare
dire je suis pas sûr ça change grand
chose aujourd'hui puisque il me paraît
pas très prêt à faire ce qu'on a fait
dans d'autres pays c'est à dire des
confinement strict et eux ont baissé le
r et quant à la vaccination et comme
elle continuera à la vitesse actuelle et
c'est à dire que ça sera se passera l'an
parce que ce qu'on voit dans les
animations aujourd'hui c'est plus des
gens de 80 ans c'est déjà 50 60 ans et
souvent des gens qui ont des enfants en
collège au lycée et ceux là vont
continuer parce qu'ils seront pas
vaccinés avant le mois de mai juin au
milieu vous avez parlé du r1 je reprends
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas le rc
le le taux de reproduction du virus
on a évoqué hier emmanuel macron ne sais
pas s'il va parler ou pas demain ou plus
tard
messieurs en tous les cas on est le 30
mars aujourd'hui il ya quatre semaines
début mars
regardez ce qui est manuel macro et
gabriel atta le porte parole du
gouvernement disait pendant quatre à six
semaines on va devoir encore passer par
des phases de gros temps par des phases
de remous par des phases difficiles
ce qui est certain c'est que la
vaccination c'est un progrès majeur dans
la lutte contre cette épidémie on
commence à observer les tout premiers
signes de l'impact de la vaccination sur
certains publics particulièrement
vulnérable sur le nombre de foyers de
contamination dans les ehpad qui
diminuent sur le taux d'incidence sur
les personnes très âgées les plus de 80
ans qui semble commencer à diminuer
c'est très préliminaire mais c'est un
signe voilà donc gabriel atteint qui
disait il faut attendre quatre à six
semaines
il faut encore tenir il parlait un le
lendemain puisque c'était le 1er mars 5
emmanuel macron avait dit il faut tenir
encore quatre à six semaines
bon là ça fait quatre semaines donc font
attendre encore attendre deux semaines
pour avoir les fameuses six semaines
mais mais bon à force est de constater
que le calendrier de sortie de crise en
tous les cas il
échange sans cesse alors vous comprenez
que les français ont besoin de voir le
bout du tunnel
pierre interne amiens non je pense que
là si vous voulez y avait une
déclaration qui était on va dire
beaucoup trop précoce parce que si on
avait pris des mesures de confinement
strict il ya quatre ou six semaines il
ya quatre semaines
on serait absolument pas dans le
désastre sanitaire qu'on va vivre
pendant les quinze jours trois semaines
il faut quand même se rendre compte que
sur ma région le taux d'incidence
demande pratiquement entre 10 30 points
tous les jours on est actuellement
pourrait bien tomber à 1 800 cas pour
100000 habitants par exemple dans le val
d'oise
oui mais bon sur d'autres régions qui a
été très impacté si vous voulez sur la
première vague la deuxième vague aussi
on était légèrement en retrait mais le
problème si vous voulez c'est
qu'actuellement on est d'accord que sur
une toute petite frange de la population
on a un effet un impact on commence à
avoir un impact sur la vaccination mais
je rejoins tout à fait ce que dit mon
confrère cirque l'impact de la
vaccination on va la voir à la fin de
l'été parce que c'est plus un taux de
couverture à 70% qu'il faudra
probablement ses taux de couverture à
95%
on est actuellement si vous voulez en
arriver cette semaine à millions de
vaccins astrazeneca l'espère prochaine
ses 300 milles et la semaine d'après ces
trois cent mille donc quelque part si
vous voulez on apprenait on est dans
l'incapacité de protéger la population
et comme on n'a pas pris des mesures
courageuses il ya à peu près trois
semaines au moment où commençait à voir
la remontée et on était nombreux a quand
même fait remarquer l'impérieuse
nécessité déjà de faire respecter les
consignes actuelles
donc ouais donc quand on vous écoute ça
veut dire qu emmanuel macron aurait dû
donc confiné en fin janvier début
février quand il avait pris donc ce pari
politique de ne pas le faire la semaine
dernière j'avais le conseil européen à
l'issue duquel il s'est exprimé jeudi
soir il a estimé qu'il avait bien fait
de ne par confiner
philippe freu gueule quand vous entendez
le président parlait ainsi le bout du
tunnel c'est con selon vous on sait
qu'alain vos confrères en djillali
annane le chef du service de réanimation
de l'hôpital raymond poincaré à garches
et a10 pas dix ans avant de revenir à la
normale en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que horna tant qu'on n'aura pas 80 85 %
au moins des gens ils sont usés que ce
soit parce qu'ils ont fait la maladie ou
parce qu'ils ont été vaccinées on aura
beaucoup beaucoup de monde très malade
et et des gens dans les hôpitaux parce
que ça touche de plus en plus des
personnes relativement jeunes et c'est
ça notre problème aujourd'hui est qu'on
va avoir
pendant le printemps pendant tout un
temps quoi qu'on fasse aujourd'hui c'est
bien ça qui est dramatique c'est que la
seule chose qu'on a à faire pour
diminuer ces faire ce que le président
macron ne veut pas et à décourager à peu
près là toute la population de le faire
c'est à dire un confinement très fort
comme on attend on a eu en angleterre
malgré la vaccination ou comme en israël
comme certains autres pays
aujourd'hui on n'a pas le choix c'est
pas c'est pas pareil et et de coeur mais
leur activation sera très lente ne
touchent pas aujourd'hui les cibles du
virus principal puisque dans les ehpad
ils ont été vaccinées mais n'hésite pas
terminions personnes et et pour le reste
si on ne protège pas les jambes par des
mesures de confinement par la fermeture
des écoles et autres
eh bien on sait ce qui va se passer dans
les trois mois qui viennent ensuite j'en
sais rien le pic de la deuxième vague
est franchie on le redit le chiffre ce
soir
5000 patients en soins critiques donc le
monde médical est pessimiste vous êtes
pessimiste vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure à philippe froguel regarder
également la sortie tout à l'heure de
l'un de vos confrères jean-françois
timsit le chef de réanimation de
l'hôpital bichat à paris
je peux le dire sans être grand clerc
dont deux semaines on aura six cents
morts par jour ce sont les personnes qui
se contaminent aujourd'hui que l'on
verra en réanimation dans quinze jours
on est déjà dans la nasse jean-françois
timsit qui a déploré également récemment
ya un an on applaudissait les médecins
le
médical et soignant et que maintenant
les médecins et tout ce monde tout ce
personnel soignant est bien est
considéré comme le père fouettard 600
morts par jour dans deux semaines
il faut quoi alors faut fermer les
écoles pour sauver l'hôpital c'est ça
mais si on ferme les écoles les parents
gardent leurs enfants ils vont pas
travailler
donc du coup l'économie chute la santé
moral des français s'effondre également
c'est cornélien comme situation
c'est je dirais la situation est
d'autant plus cornélienne que s'ils
voulaient on a fait un pêché d'orgueil
on s'est basé sur l'angle à l'angleterre
où il avait on va dire commencer à voir
une accélération on va dire de la
dégradation de la situation à peu près
45 % de varier anglais je parle sous le
contrôle revient de mon confrère
et c'est vrai qu'en france jusqu'à
pratiquement 60%
la france a peu bougé les chiffres n'ont
pas été on va dire mauvais et donc
probablement le gouvernement s'est dit
en battant on va attendre et maintenant
on est dans une situation des patients
jeunes à des enfants qui sont
contaminants et qui arrive directement
quasiment l'animation parce que les samu
les récupère dans un état qui n'est pas
bon et donc on a plus si vous voulez en
plus ce voleur de sécurité que
représentaient les sept huit jours en
hospitalisation avant que certains
d'entre eux par pourcentage basculant
rien donc on s'est retrouvé
littéralement devant un mur où on a une
arrivée massive et je dirais ont
peut-être en train de payer ce qu'on n'a
pas osé faire on va dire il ya peu près
trois semaines parce que là maintenant
on est dans le dur dit aux étudiants
ferme les écoles c'est ça on parle
beaucoup en ce moment de fermer les
écoles
oui je pense que si vous voulez là le
taux de reproduction est
particulièrement élevé on va dire dans
la tranche 17 21 ans
hélas ça flambe mais le problème si vous
voulez c'est quand vous avez une mesure
de confinement et que vous ne la
respectez pas là ça ne marche pas on
peut dire qu'on a un confinement qui est
relativement valable sur le papier le
problème c'est qu'il parle
l'acceptabilité des français ou bien les
français ne sont pas on va dire
consignant il ne respecte pas il n'en
font qu'à leur tête c'est ça philippe
froguel
je pense que l'exode gano le président
macro on nous a dit en gros les médecins
sont des empêcheurs de vivre en rond et
ça sert à rien confinement est donc le
fait pas et donc à partir de ce moment
là maintenant on a tous vu ce qui se
passe le week-end personne ne prend au
sérieux le nez au confinement qui a été
mis en place et à 15 jours et je crains
que quoi qu'il arrive donc on sera pas
mobilisés moi j'ai vécu deux exemples
inverses c'est-à-dire roubaix au moins
de novembre et dunkerque il ya quinze
jours
et bien c'est pas les mesures de
confinement qu'on fait quelque chose
c'est quand la population de roubaix à
huîtres très peur et collectivement ils
ont décidé de faire attention et ça a
duré jusqu'en janvier quand j'ai fait le
dépistage de masse en jambes dit
et personne n'atteint c'était incroyable
à dunkerque vous allez voir ça va parce
que dans les gens sont mobilisés ils le
font c'est pas la peur du gendarme qui
d'ailleurs se montre peu c'est pas parce
que monsieur matheron durable en noir
c'est parce que la société aura décidé
de faire attention
hélas hélas tous les cas on se
retiennent pas ce cas là on a attendu
gérald darmanin dans le sujet d'un
mariage sous blair oui enfin le nom de
genre je connais qui vont qui vont
partir en week-end
j'en connais beaucoup donc je ne pense
pas que tout le monde fasse très
attention donc pointe simplement à ce
que je veux dire c'est que le président
matheron à jouer à l'apprenti sorcier en
faisant que plus personne n'a eu peur
plus personne n'a voulu se confiner et
on est quand on a 10 4 ou 6 semaines
vous l'avez pas c'est tout à l'heure ça
voulait dire qu'on fait un pas qu'on
allait de vivre une vie normale et bah
c'est pas possible
si on fait ça ça va être le drame et je
suis vraiment désolé pour tous les
français c'est que la réalité est plus
simple que ce que le président m'a cran
avait prévu philippe froguel je reprends
vos de sémantique un apprenti sorcier
emmanuel macron tous les cas qui est en
baisse dans les sondages on s'est
tellement de notre débat skis emmanuel
macron et seul envers et contre tout et
contre tous
regardez ce sondage les français qui
critiquent
sa gestion de la crise sanitaire selon
un récent sondage la doxa denso
consulting pour la presse quotidienne
régionale 55% sanctionne la politique de
tests de dépistage 67% dénonce la
politique vaccinale 76% déploie une
mauvaise communication notamment en ce
qui concerne le vaccin astrazeneca
messieurs pour terminer j'ai pas le pas
de langue de bois s'il vous plaît j'ai
cette question politique même si vous
n'êtes pas des politiques parce qu'il
s'est écoulé un an depuis le début de
cette crise on a pointé
les problèmes liés à l'hôpital quand il
y avait eu ce qui s'était passé à
mulhouse il ya un hôpital militaire qui
s'écrit rapidement on a dit on va créer
des lits supplémentaires
et quand on entend par exemple le
professeur timsit dire si jamais demain
vous avez deux malades qui viennent en
réanimation qu'est ce que vous faites je
vais pousser les murs il dit je vais
mettre un lit dans le couloir peut-être
ça veut dire qu'on n'a pas créé délit
donc cette question politique est ce que
le système de
politique de l'hôpital est ce que c'est
le vrai problème plutôt que mettre de
l'argent dans le confinement les mesures
de freinage qui coûte très cher à
l'économie qu'il fallait pas créer des
lits à l'hôpital et pas être en flux
tendus comme souvent le sytème hôpital
hospitalier elle est très rapidement
messieurs tous les deux répondre à cette
question compliquée et politiquement
surproduit l'hôpital de mulhouse
l'hôpital militaire
je peux vous garantir que quand il s'est
monté le médecin parfums les médecins
militaires qui sont arrivés sont allés
voir le pharmacien de l'hôpital du
milieu en disant on est là mais on a
zéro matériel 0 médicaments pour nous en
fournir et qu'il les a regardés en dix
ans mais moi j'ai rien je suis déjà en
pénurie complet donc il ya un effet
d'annonce il ya zéro efficacité
on avait un an pour essayer de former du
personnel parce que la richesse d'une
nation c'est le personnel sait les
soignants on avait un an pour former
on va dire à vitesse rapide des
infirmiers des aides soignants le
médecin s'est je dirais on est coincé il
s'est tellement long mais pour former
des gens pour s'occuper des patients
rien on n'a strictement rien fait
philippe froguel rapidement répondre
également à cette question en un an donc
on n'a rien fait l'attentisme il est
toujours présent on attend toujours une
prise de parole dans des manuels macron
la réanimation pour des gens de 40 ou 50
ans est inacceptable et ne devrait pas
avoir ces gens surtout dans les pays où
il ya plus jeune le plus de morts comme
en angleterre et on est aujourd'hui la
question est pas de compter les
réanimations skiff rendait ce qui est
dramatique pour pour les personnes qui y
sont et après quand ils en ressortent
ça aura été d'avoir une vraie politique
vaccinale avoir des vaccins comme en
angleterre comme aux etats-unis comme en
israël de les distribuer correctement
comme dans d'autres pays voire de l'éco
d'en commander d'autres comme fait la
cave a fait l'autriche aujourd'hui et
puis faire des mesures de confinement
sur un visage lui de commander
du spoutnik vert il a dit notamment par
exemple en tout cas il est confiné voir
ce qu'on peut faire aujourd'hui pour le
restants on va pas ouvrir évadés
réanimation et on n'a pas le personnel
ni matériel ni rien pour faire ça c'est
des paroles verbales ça comme on dit
merci en tous les cas messieurs 1 pierre
jeantet en amiante philippe froguel
d'avoir répondu à nos questions à
remercier d'avoir été franc et direct
dans d'envoi réponse pas de langue de
bois ce soir sur arte france donc par là
parlera parlera pas d'un côté et votre à
votre a pas de l'autre la crise
sanitaire plus que jamais trouble-fête
des scrutins électoraux également
prochaines échéances dans le viseur les
régionales en juin les responsables de
la majorité est les rebelles ont évoqué
ce matin lors d'une réunion avec le
premier ministre à jean castex la
possibilité de laisser les
parlementaires se prononcer sur la
question
une consultation à laquelle semblent
favorables et différentes formations
politiques
hier dans son rapport le conseil
scientifique a botté en touche laissant
à l'exécutif le soin de prendre cette
décision et je cite éminemment politique
la question sera tranchée avant jeudi
pour parler des élections territoriales
alexis poulain c'est l'édito
[Musique]
bonsoir alexis poulain merci de répondre
à notre question un nouveau report des
élections régionales est il envisageable
oui tout est envisageable comme aime à
le dire la majorité présidentielle
toutes les options sont sur la table
donc un report comme autre chose alors
ce qui est évidemment embêtant pour le
président de la république et le premier
ministre sait que le conseil
scientifique n'a pas joué le jeu il a
décidé de ne pas décider et de faire
comme vous l'avez dit et bien simplement
de renvoyer en touche et de dire c'est
aux politiques de faire un choix
éminemment politique celui de reporter
ou non une élection démocratique et cela
en toute transparence parce que derrière
ce choix de vouloir reporter une
élection il y à un calcul politique
celui de dire eh bien après l'échec
cuisant aux municipales rappelez vous la
république en marche avait fait 2 2 %
sur les listes où elle était déclarée et
bien des régionales ne s'annonçait pas
sous de meilleurs auspices les ténors de
la majorité comme jean michel blanquer
où certains ministres n'ont pas voulu y
aller sachant que la défaite était
assuré au bout du scrutin et donc cette
idée sanitaire de reporter et bien elle
est dans la tête de l'exécutif
hélas le conseil scientifique ne veut
pas jouer la caution est dit c'est à
vous de choisir alors ça va devenir
compliqué parce que en décalant ces
régionales
l'idée si c'est après l'été par exemple
ce serait de couper l'herbe sous le pied
à de nombreux candidats à la
présidentielle qui viendrait de ces
régions on pense aux présidents de
région importants notamment à droite
valérie pécresse laurent wauquiez xavier
bertrand qui vient de se déclarer
candidat eh bien si la campagne ne peut
pas avoir lieu maintenant l'élection ne
peut pas avoir lieu en juin
alors il leur faudra à tous choisir
l'elysée où la région est là clairement
l'opposition dans l'est région dira que
s'ils se font élire pour ce quelques
mois seulement il pour partir même pas
quelques semaines et pour partir
immédiatement en campagne pour la
présidentielle
ça ne tiendra pas et c'est une campagne
qui est impossible pour eux donc c'est
un calcul évidemment simple et facile
mais ça ne peut pas marcher comme ça et
là aujourd'hui
et cultive va devoir prendre une
décision qui sera commentée scruter et
d'ailleurs contredite par beaucoup
l'opposition comme d'ailleurs la
majorité elle est menée contre ce report
des élections parce que beaucoup de pays
tiennent des élections même encore
heures en temps de crise sanitaire et au
delà de cette tactique politicienne dont
vous parlez il n'y a pas de derrière une
raison sanitaire quand même évidente à
retarder un scrutin on a en mémoire les
élections municipales notamment vecteurs
de contamination
oui alors on se rappelle tous les
élections de mars élections municipales
de 2020 ou les assesseurs d'ailleurs ont
payé un lourd tribut puisque ceux qui
ont dépouillé
certains en sont morts beaucoup ont
rattrapé le coc vides à cette occasion
mais le contexte n'est pas le même
aujourd'hui on connaît ce virus on a des
masques on est équipé on a commencé une
campagne de vaccination et si les
objectifs sont tenues 10 millions 20
millions 30 millions de français
vaccinés à partir de l'été alors il n'y
a pas de raison d'annuler pour des
raisons sanitaires ces élections
d'autant plus que à l'époque des
élections municipales il y avait un
rapport qui était sortie en sortie par
l'ap-hp qui disait qu' il y avait
finalement dû très peu de cas qu'ils
avaient été déclarés suite aux élections
municipales
et si il y avait eu des cas c'est parce
que les assesseurs était impliqué dans
la vie politique locale avait fait
campagne et donc avait rencontré
beaucoup de personnes donc le débat il a
eu lieu il n'y a pas de raison de
l'avoir à nouveau sur la raisons
sanitaires
ce serait un aveu d'échec d'ailleurs de
dire que à la fois la campagne de
vaccination n'a pas fonctionné parce que
nous manquons de doses de vaccins que
vous êtes incapable d'organiser la
logistique de cette vaccination
et puis de dire aussi pourquoi la france
ce grand pays 7
ordination qui est capable de démocratie
est incapable d'organiser des élections
là où d'autres pays l'ont fait sans
problème je pense plus récemment à
israël qui vient d'organiser des
élections où les malades du kobe tu
pouvais voter même à l'hôpital on peut
organiser un scrutin il s'agit de
volonté il s'agit aussi un peu
d'organisation logistique
alors c'est vrai quand on voit
l'organisation de la campagne vaccinale
on peut se demander effectivement si
aujourd'hui les responsables au sommet
de l'état sont capables d'organiser une
logistique comme celle d'élections mais
alors là ça pose une question plus
profonde que celle de la vaccination
c'est celle de la démocratie est ce
qu'on est aujourd'hui capable en france
d'organiser des élections
c'est la vraie question qui doit se
poser si on les annuler pour cause de
crise sanitaire
alors la question la plus profonde et
quelles seraient les conséquences d'un
report des élections régionales alors
les conséquences elles sont évidentes
d'abord il y a c'est tout l'intérêt
finalement des manades micro et de sa
majorité
premièrement c'est couper l'herbe sous
le pied comme je le disais à des
candidats qui serait dangereux pour
emmanuel macron lors de l'élection
présidentielle si jamais il se
représentait pour un second mandat
parce qu'il faudra choisir entre la
région où le pays est donc là c'est
gagnant uniquement d'un côté c'est à
dire pour les mails mâcon deuxièmement
si on repousse les élections après l'été
le bilan sera beaucoup plus positif pour
emmanuel macron à la fois parce que la
campagne de vaccination aura eu lieu
parce que l'été sera passé par là et
donc le virus aura naturellement baisser
par les conditions climatiques et donc
mma qu'on pourra dire qu'il a été
fantastique dans sa gestion de crise en
faisant oublier le fiasco des masques le
fiasco des tests le fiasco de la
vaccination les fiascos déconfinement
des couvre feux etc etc et en disant que
finalement son action héroïque a été
formidable et que donc il va se
présenter avec un bilan génial pour lrm
qui est par ailleurs devenue une
étiquette plutôt perdante où les députés
de la majorité essaye de se cacher en
fait derrière un paravent d'une majorité
présidentielle beaucoup plus large et
puis troisièmement c'est créer les
conditions d'une relance parce que le
plan de relance va rentrer en action
le seconde
semestre va permettre de sauver
davantage d'entreprises avec l'argent
magique de l'union européenne et donc de
financer déjà une précampagne des
malades maquereau en disant que
l'économie ne va pas si mal que
l'effondrement n'a pas lieu et que donc
il faut lui faire confiance parce qu'il
est un leader formidable comme tout
d'ailleurs les membres de son parti donc
trois raisons utile pour est mal macron
de faire cette solution du report des
élections
mais c'est quand même insupportable la
ficelle est énorme
comment se fait-il qu'en france des
millions de citoyens soient suspendues
au choix d'un seul ça ça s'appelle
l'ancien régime et de mémoire ça s'est
très mal fini plus tôt avec derrière
d'ailleurs à régime difficile et donc
après la révolution
donc ce n'est pas souhaitable je crois
qu'il faut remettre au contraire
davantage de démocratie il faudrait que
ces élections aient lieu et ne surtout
pas bousculer les calendriers électoraux
de fêtes de virus parce que ce serait
dangereux pour la démocratie française
merci alex et poulain pour cette
intervention je rappelle que vous êtes
notre éditorialiste bientôt 20h30 heure
française
très heureux de vous retrouver sur rt
france la france on l'a dit ne sait pas
sur quel pied danser face aux possibles
futures mesures de freinage sanitaire
royaume uni de son côté commence à
entrevoir le bout du tunnel au lendemain
d'un happy mondays traduisez lundi
heureux synonyme de déconfinement
progressif
les britanniques ray apprivoise leur
liberté en profitant des parcs et des
activités sportives de plein air si la
question de la fermeture des écoles
françaises se posent les établissements
scolaires d'outre-manche eux ont rouvert
depuis le 8 mars
le londonien profite donc de la levée
progressive des restrictions après avoir
payé un lourd tribut 127000 mordu
coronavirus et plus de deux mois à 2
mise sous cloche strictes nous n'avons
pas nagé depuis le 5 janvier
alors nous étions très excités de
pouvoir revenir et de nous remettre dans
l'eau je suis passé devant tous les
jours j'ai pu voir le cours fermées je
suis impatient de frapper la balle
aujourd'hui absolument merveilleux le
début d'une nouvelle et belle liberté
toujours dans le respect des règles les
britanniques qui retrouvent le sourire
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
avec bharat bank kenya il est expert en
maladies infectieuses à l'université
d'exeter
[Musique]
le losc a distingué deux gammes in waves
ce n'est pas une question de prix à
gagner ou qui a perdu l'épidémie
arrivent par vagues
ce qui arrive en france et peut
également arriver au royaume uni la
grande différence est que le royaume uni
a vacciné une large partie du groupe
fragile vulnérable des plus âgés sont
protégés l'autre différence et notre
long confinement qui a fait baisser le
nombre de cas en france malheureusement
la courbe des cas restent élevés car
votre compliment
la pâte est strict et la vaccination n'a
pas non plus été aussi rapide des achats
in app engine for speed
aïda non notre et or pas du tout il faut
être prudent a l'air attentif
ce virus ne respecte pas les frontières
ou les démarcations le point positif est
que les personnes âgées au royaume uni
sont partiellement immunisés grâce au
vaccin mais il ya encore un long chemin
à parcourir
un message au royaume uni et soyez
prudents soyez attentifs
faute de quoi il pourrait y avoir une
nouvelle flambée comme dans l'union
européenne
mais big apple just like d'ailleurs aux
pionniers des vaccins campaign has been
to prevent sévérité envers elles ne
savent qu aux dettes avec sa compagne
vaccinale prévient c'est prouvé les
formes graves et donc la mort le vaccin
est très bon cependant nous ne serons
pas hors de danger
tant que tout le monde ne sera pas rare
de danger nous espérons vacciner le
monde entier jusqu'à ce qu'un nombre
important de personnes soient vaccinés
dans l'union européenne et dans le monde
nous ne sommes pas hors de danger
le virus peut changer invariants peut
émerger avec les nombreuses
contaminations dans l'union européenne
l'afrique l'inde et caetera et le virus
peut voyager jusqu'au royaume uni s'il
résistait aux vaccins ce serait un
retour à la case départ
il faut être prudent travailler avec la
communauté internationale afin de
s'assurer que l'union européenne
l'afrique l'asie et l'amérique du sud
souhaite également vaccinés aussi
rapidement que possible et menaces
possibles à tout moment à l'être en ce
moment et il n'y aurait eu ni une légère
pénurie dans l'approvisionnement
la stratégie est de dispenser leur
seconde dose aux personnes concernées
puis de vacciner les personnes plus
jeunes
lorsque les deux seront disponibles on
ne va pas réduire le vaccin une seule
dose nous recevons de données et les
personnes qui n'ont pas encore été
vaccinés
le saurons un peu plus tard
hu et nice où est la bonne nouvelle avec
l'arrivée de plusieurs nouvelles
plateformes vaccinale et qu'il y aura
des deux en surplus et il relèverait des
bonnes pratiques de santé publique de
santé mondiale de partager ces doses les
stockés dans des hangars serait inutile
le plus important est de les partager
avec les régions dynamiques plus pauvres
afin que d'autres gens puissent
également être protégés ce la meilleure
stratégie pour la santé publique et la
santé mondiale stratégies londres qui
sort du brouillard mais l'organisation
mondiale de la santé toujours dans le
flou quant à l'origine du comité 19
le patron de l'om est-ce réclament
aujourd'hui une nouvelle enquête sur
l'hypothèse d'une fuite du conte à virus
d'un laboratoire en chine il critique au
passage le partage insuffisant des
données par pékin lors de la mission des
experts internationaux cet hiver
déclaration au lendemain de la
publication du rapport qui revient sur
l'origine de la pandémie au sein duquel
l'hypothèse d'une fuite d'un laboratoire
il a été qualifié je cite de très peu
probable personne n'a été en mesure de
recueillir des arguments solides des
preuves ou des évidences que ces
laboratoires ou l'un de ses laboratoires
auraient été impliqués dans les
accidents de laboratoire bien sûr se
produisent de temps en temps nous
l'avons vu à travers l'histoire dans
plusieurs endroits
donc oui c'est possible
cela fait également partie des
conclusions du rapport
selon lesquelles ce n'est pas impossible
que cela se soit produit
mais nous n'avons pas vu ou entendu
quelque chose ou qui justifierait les
conclusions différentes
la chine souvent pointé du doigt par les
états unis par rapport à l'origine du
comité 19 sous l'administration entrup
sous l'administration byden plus de
prudence vis-à-vis du cornât virus la
guerre contre le sras skov de est loin
d'être gagnée selon le 46e président
américain isabelle carré skos objectif
90% le à feu lors d'une allocution
depuis la maison blanche lundi
joe biden s'est montré pour le moins
optimiste
90 % c'est le taux d'américains qui
seront selon lui éligibles à la
vaccination d'ici le 19 avril prochain
soit dans trois semaines seulement
durant les trois derniers jours nous
avons administré un nombre record
d'injection avec plus de 10 millions
d'injections pendant le week end
plus de 10 millions d'injections trois
jours cela aurait été inconcevable en
janvier et ce n'est pas tout 90 % sera
aussi selon lui le pourcentage de
citoyens américains qui auront accès à
un centre de vaccination à moins de 8
kilomètres de leur domicile dont le même
ton le président américain a lancé une
mise en garde en affirmant que la guerre
contre locaux vides 19 est loin d'être
gagné le programme de vaccination
pourrait encore faire face à un revers
et surtout si nous baissons la guerre
maintenant le virus pourrait empirer
non pas s'améliorer une intensification
de la campagne de vaccination pour le
moins ambitieuse alors que la pandémie
fait toujours près de mille morts par
jour aux états unis et que depuis une
semaine
soixante mille nouveaux cas quotidiens
sont confirmés mais cette vaccination
massive serait selon les autorités
rendu possible par l'augmentation des
livraisons de flacons de vaccin dans le
pays et par la multiplication des
centres de vaccination ainsi que par
l'augmentation du nombre de pharmacies
autorisé à procéder aux injections
depuis lundi déjà certains états comme
l'ohio le texas ont élargi les gie
milité au vaccin à tous les adultes de
plus de 16 ans
un soulagement pour les personnes qui
souhaitent se faire vacciner je me sens
quelque sorte soulagé et c'est en
quelque sorte excitant parce que c'est
comme si on arrivait enfin à la fin de
toute cette folle période maintenant que
nous nous faisons tous vaccinés
c'est comme si on arrivait à la fin de
tout ça et c'est bien je suis très
heureuse que nous puissions accueillir
tout le monde
c'est difficile lorsque l'on doit
refuser des personnes en raison de
certaines circonstances
donc cela nous permet de pouvoir
atteindre toutes les personnes possible
et qui veulent recevoir ce vaccin contre
le coc vite 19 lundi joe biden a aussi
appelé des gouverneurs et des mères qui
avait levé l'obligation du port du
masque dans leurs états à faire machine
arrière en évoquant un devoir
patriotique
une semaine après la barre symbolique
des 300 mille victimes du sras skov de
franchir au brésil l'inquiétude grandit
en amérique latine argentine chili pérou
ou encore venezuela
tour d'horizon signé di mare aux siens
de buenos aires à caracas le sascoc de
gagne de nouveau du terrain
en cause notamment l'une de ces
mutations le variant brésilien qui se
répand à travers le continent sud
américain et qui entraîne une hausse
flagrante des contaminations comme en
argentine où plus de 14 mille nouveaux
cas ont été confirmés ce lundi soit le
triple d'il ya un mois
le virus a déjà fait cinquante cinq
mille victimes dans le pays où plus d'un
lit de réanimation sur deux est occupé
les frontières terrestres sont toujours
fermées et les autorités ont suspendu
les vols en provenance du mexique du
brésil et du chili le chili justement la
situation sanitaire n'est pas plus
glorieuse malgré le succès de la
campagne de vaccination plus d'un tiers
de la population est déjà reçu une
première dose
ce qui fait du chili un champion en
amérique latine
malgré ce titre le pays connaît de
nouveau record de contamination et 80%
des chiliens sont confinés depuis samedi
dernier
dimanche le président sebastian pinera a
annoncé un report de l'élection
constituante initialement prévue le 10
avril entre les éthers et au chili
cette nouvelle vague signifie que
davantage de personnes sont infectées et
davantage de patients hospitalisés ce
qui a poussé notre personnel médical et
notre système de santé à la limite de
leurs capacités et à la capacité à l'est
du continent le brésil connaît lui une
explosion épidémique
le deuxième pays le plus endeuillé au
monde avec plus de 300000 morts déplore
ces derniers jours des records de
mortalité liée aux qu'ovide avec
plusieurs milliers de nouveaux décès
quotidiens 17 millions de doses ont déjà
été administrées
ce qui n'empêche pas des vaccinations
clandestine voir des détournements du
sérum le vaccin le nerf de la guerre
également au venezuela caracas a refusé
l'astra zelekha par précaution et ne
bénéficie pour le moment pas du
dispositif dead kovacs en raison de
dettes envers l'om est le pays qui a
donc cruellement besoin de vaccin a
toutefois reçu ce lundi une troisième
livraison de spoutnik v et attend 60
mille doses de la part de cuba son
président nicolas smad bureau a par
ailleurs lancé un appel pour un échange
de vaccins contre de l'or noir
le venezuela a des pétroliers à des
clients prêts à nous acheter du pétrole
il consacrerait une partie de sa
production pour obtenir les vaccins dont
il a besoin du pétrole contre des
vaccins nous sommes prêts et préparés du
pétrole contre les vaccins
le pays connaît par ailleurs un
confinement strict depuis une dizaine de
jours
tout comme le paraguay depuis samedi
avec des services de réanimation saturés
des hôpitaux au bord de l'effondrement
au pérou également qui a enregistré il y
a une semaine un record de nombre de cas
même le voisin uruguayen dont la gestion
de la pandémie était saluée jusque là
fait face à ses plus mauvais chiffres de
contamination et de mortalité
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
une reprise épidémique qui devrait
vraisemblablement touché les pays
voisins d'amérique centrale et notamment
le mexique troisième pays le plus
endeuillé au monde avec plus de 200000
morts
le virus ils refluent depuis plusieurs
semaines mais le variant brésilien
pourrait bien changer la donne et on
parle de l'amérique latine avec la
journaliste
gabriella bravo spécialiste du continent
sud américain bonsoir gabriela bravo
merci de répondre à nos questions en
direct sur arte france ce soir donc
brésil argentine chili venezuela pérou
ça fait beaucoup de pays avant de se
focaliser sur une nation ou une autre
globalement comment expliquer cette
situation est ce qu'on peut mettre ça
sur le compte des variants brésilien il
ya masioni est amazonien comme on vient
de le voir sur le sujet de guillemin
ruse rossi ou bien à ce que ces
politiques d'un mélange des deux d'un
côté il ya les variantes l'arrivée des
du variant britannique mais c'est
surtout les variantes brésilienne qui en
fait beaucoup de mal à l'amérique du sud
parce que c'est long les
épidémiologistes latino américains les
vrais cl c'est un terreau où ils peuvent
se développer des différents variant
puisque l'épidémie est complètement hors
de contrôle dans ce pays
d'accord aussi il faut savoir qu'elle
devrait cl clp qui à la frontière la
plus grande avec la plus grande quantité
des pays de l'amérique du sud
donc c'est varioleux varions d'émana ans
le variant de rien des généraux ont
commencé à passer les frontières
ça s'est envolé mais il ya l'autre volet
que c'est les politiques d chaque pays
ce qu'on a vu c'est que après un nom des
pandémies déconne à virus les pays ils
sont commencé à relâcher les mesures
sanitaires car c'est là que c'est
beaucoup de crises sociales les
enfermant l'est
couvre faire et tous les mesures de
restriction des libertés
il savait provoqué aussi dans certains
pays des crises sociales majeures
donc les nouvelles variantes brésilienne
et des larmes en 2d relâchement des
mesures sanitaires ont provoqué une
flambée de l'épidémie dans l'amérique du
sud
plusieurs causes à cette flambée de co
leader en amérique du sud
on se focalise sur l'argentine qui a
commencé sa campagne vaccinale le vin le
29 décembre
mais selon trois millions de personnes
ont été vaccinées pourquoi on peut
parler de l'art gentil mais c'est le
problème de plusieurs pays de l'amérique
latine l'amérique du sud et l problème
c'est que les pays riches les pays
développés ont accaparé le marché des
vaccins les pays développés représentent
16% de la population et sont achetés 60%
des vaccins donc les pays du sud n'ont
pas accès à une grande quantité et des
vaccins et soit l'argentine le brésil
paraguay
ils sont commencé une campagne de
vaccination mais sinon pas les vaccins
il ne peut pas avancer si rapidement les
seuls pays qui qui sait de marque de
sens et le chili le pays qui a pu
négocier avec nous à la bombe des
vaccins avec différents laboratoires et
qu' il ya eu un échange avec des
laboratoires chinois ce qui a permis d
pouvoir accéder un grand nombre des
vaccins et on voit que celle troisième
pays au monde les plus vaccinée en ce
moment 33% la population chilienne
vacciner
troisième derrière israël est derrière
la grande bretagne mais pourtant le
président chilien sebastian pinera
envisage le report des élections
constitutionnel est énorme plassard
confinement strict comment est-ce que
vous l'expliquer exactement ça on
l'appeler la paddock chilienne c'est à
dire que les chiliens se sont fait
vacciner massivement et ils sont et se
sont complètement relâché les messieurs
sanitaires ont été complètement relâchée
ces qui a provoqué une flambée des
l'épidémie dans ces dernières semaines
ces dernières jours parce que il faut
savoir que le vaccin n'est pas une
baguette magique qui fait disparaître
tout de suite
l'épidémie il faut avoir déjà les deux
vaccins et après il faut attendre deux
semaines pour pouvoir avoir l'immunité
néanmoins les chiliens et se sont senti
protégé par le vaccin oms par sept et
succès pour cette campagne de
vaccination et ils sont relâchés dans le
port des masques dont aussi la
distanciation social c'est qui a donné
comme résultat une explosion des cas et
une flambée de l'épidémie
tout ce qui n'est pas très encourageant
et évidemment pour pour les semaines à
venir
un message d alerte donc pour pour les
personnes qui se font vacciner
évidemment mais pour revenir également
sur ce qui se passe en amérique du sud
il ya les scandales des vaccinations
vieilles pies des ministres qui devance
la population grâce à leurs réseaux ça
fait couler beaucoup d'encre comment se
positionne la population par rapport à
cette problématique en argentine
notamment avec les passe-droits c'est
monnaie courante
ce qu'on a vu on tend différents pays à
l'argentine l'équateur le brésil même le
venezuela des personnes qu'ils n'ont pas
respecté les propres politiques
sanitaires qui ont été imposées à leurs
citoyens
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qui se passe ça ça
fait très mal à la démocratie
ça fait m ça fait penser aux gens cette
idée d tous corrompus
une classe politique qui préfère entre
guillemets c'est sauver tout seul au
détriment de sa propre population
c'est qui fait très mal à la démocratie
en amérique latine mais aussi sacré d un
conflit social parce que ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que la sortie de cette
pandémie va faire peut-être va jouer un
rôle majeur dans les événements après
pandémie c'est à dire on va vivre une
crise économique et sociale et le
comportement des dirigeants de
l'amérique du sud va était est scruté
par les citoyens et des scandales comme
les vaccins vip bien aussi entaché cette
l'idée d une classe politique corrompue
et qui ne se soucie pas des ses propres
concitoyens autres pays le venezuela
avec le président à nicholas maduro qui
propose du pétrole en échange de vaccins
en amérique du
plus qu'ailleurs les vaccins sont
géopolitique exactement c'est un enjeu
majeur en ce moment d'abord parce que la
sortie de la pandémie dès la sortie de
la pandémie va dépendre entre guillemets
la tête des plusieurs dirigeants
comment et sans quand ils sont arrivés à
surmonter
comme ils sont mis des politiques
en pratique pour pouvoir gérer leur pays
donc d'un côté il ya le venezuela que
comme je l'avais dit ne peut pas
s'approvisionner des vaccins parce que
ils ont été accaparées par les pays
riches mais il ya tous les pays de la
région de l'amérique latine de
l'amérique du sud qui sont qui cherchent
à s'approvisionner deux vaccins pour
pouvoir sortie de ce pont d'amy qui va
sûrement coûté le poste à nombreux
dirigeants politiques de la région
merci gabriela bravo d'avoir répondu à
nos questions rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste spécialiste de l'amérique
latine pays le plus endeuillé d'amérique
du sud le brésil où un quatrième
ministre de la santé a été nommé la
semaine dernière sous le mandat de
jagger bob denard où le président
ultraconservateur brésilien qui a
procédé ces dernières heures un
remaniement ministériel important
procédant à six changements avec des
portefeuilles importants et régalien
conséquence les chefs de l'armée de
l'air de terre et de la marine quittent
leurs fonctions et la médiane c'est le
plus grand remaniement ministériel de
jaillir bulls narrow depuis son arrivée
au pouvoir il y a un peu plus de deux
ans le président brésilien a décidé de
se séparer d'un tiers de son
gouvernement
six changements de ministres à des
portefeuilles clefs comme ceux de la
justice de la défense ou encore des
affaires étrangères le seul départ
attendu depuis deux semaines était celui
du chef de la diplomatie
ernesto alors aux mises en cause dans le
fiasco de la politique anti kovy 19 du
brésil
autre poids lourd a quitté le
gouvernement le ministre de la défense
fernando azevedo et silva une démission
qui a créé la surprise dans le pays est
pris de court les observateurs un
remaniement marqué aussi par l'arrivée
de flavia arruda au secrétariat de la
présidence
en nommant cette députée du sertao le
président veut montrer son rapprochement
avec le groupe informel de
parlementaires centristes qui monnaient
leur soutien en échange de postes
importants
avec ce changement dans les hautes
sphères jaïr ball sonar au fortement
critiqué pour sa gestion de la pandémie
tente un recentrage le président
brésilien fait face à des pressions
grandissantes pour répondre avec plus de
sérieux à la crise sanitaire
le brésil a dépassé les 314 milles morts
du courant d'un virus en un an
pays le plus endeuillé au monde après
les états unis
dans quelques instants retour sur la
crise sanitaire et le côté sociétal
cette fois avec les femmes en première
ligne une étude de la fondation des
femmes dévoilées hier mettant en garde
contre un plan de relance privilégiant
des secteurs où le sexe féminin est sous
représenté et puis à zoom sur le projet
de loi comportant les principes de la
république
son examen a débuté tout à l'heure au
sénat et ce pour deux semaines a tout de
suite sur leur défense
[Musique]
vous êtes né dans la musique vous êtes
né dans une famille d'artistes désir
révélée brutalement par la prise de
conscience du concert symphonique qui
m'a donné envie d'être chef d'orchestre
ça a balayé tout le reste c'est un acte
d'amour la musique pour vous un oui mais
l'art en général vous savez ça permet de
mieux se connaître ça permet de mieux
partager c'est la part d'humanité
incontournable et indispensable à
l'évolution de tout être humain quand
vous entendez pata pata pata pata pata
pata pata pata pata pata papa parents
pata pata
vous avez envie de faire ça va aller il
faut que leur qu'istres groove la
musique c'est la traduction la plus
poétique de la vie si vous mettez pas la
vie m'a évidemment on s'embête il faut
sortir les notes de leurs univers
carcéral
mais il faut jouer ce qui a entre les
notes et avant tout c'est le rythme et
la pulsation et ça c'est fondamental
pour entraîner et l' enthousiasme des
musiciens et celui du public
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
nous sommes une équipe
[Musique]
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous-même le
maniement de la rumeur est vieux comme
le monde mais il est vrai que l'arrivée
des réseaux sociaux il va donner une
crédibilité destructrices dans sa
virtualité l'influencent a pris toute sa
place au coeur des affrontements
politiques et économiques internationaux
car elle est une manifestation de la
puissance capable de peser sur
l'évolution des situations
tous les jours nous entendons des
accusations de complotisme contre ceux
qui n'adhèrent pas à la pensée qu'on
dans le fond la théorie du complot
l'explication la plus simple et la plus
facile d'autant qu'elle permet désigner
un bouc émissaire
évidemment coupable du pire vouloir
forcer le destin en récrivant une
histoire biaisée pour servir ses
intérêts ne tient pas dans la durée car
la vérité finit toujours par éclater
[Musique]
louis saillant est un mec ce commando
marine il nous emmène dans les coulisses
de la guerre contre le djihadisme à au
sahel l'ennemi là bas est parfaitement
légitime qu'on parle de jay liste on
parle de gens qui recrutent des enfants
on parle de gens qui sont d'une barbarie
extrême c'est vrai que c'est un terreau
qui peut favoriser l'extension du
terrorisme ne faut pas imaginer qu'il
suffit simplement d'avoir un pays pauvre
pour que l'islam c'est un guillaume a
qui sont embrigadés ils ont été séduits
ils ont été manipulés et d'autres qui
agissent de manière parfaitement
consciente et lucide je respecterai
toujours l'adversaire même si je méprise
totalement son idéologie comme c'est le
cas pour sega liste
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la peuplent
c'était une volonté collective
vous le savez comme moi que dès qu'on
dit il n'y a pas d'alternative on sort
du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
souligne l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
tout
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soient pas publics
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
il ya un peu plus d'un dans le
coronavirus déferlait sur les pays
européens alors un an après on est
l'union européenne comment se porte
l'économie quelle leçon pour la zone
euro on a vu simplement que quand les
problèmes arrivent à c'est chacun pour
soi on voit qu'à chaque fois qu'on
essaie de faire un plan de relance c'est
un plan dans lequel nous versons plus
que ce que nous recevons bon que je vois
pas très bien l'intérêt de faire ce
genre de chose quelle est la valeur
ajoutée de l'union européenne dans
toutes ces négociations
aucune on voit que c'est extrêmement
compliqué aujourd'hui on regarde les les
pays et on s'aperçoit que l'europe est
encore une fois à la traîne
économiquement il ya en effet des
paroles mais il ya aucune cohérente
[Musique]
excellente soirée à toutes et à tous sur
arte france très heureux de vous
retrouver pour ces deuxièmes heures
d'information tout de suite les titres
veille d'un conseil de défense sanitaire
emmanuel macron battent ils s'exprimer
le président pressé par le corps médical
d'agir face à la flambée de kobe de 19
le chef de l'état pointé du doigt
également par une partie de la gente
féminine une étude de la fondation des
femmes dévoilées hier met en garde
contre un plan de relance privilégiant
des secteurs où le sexe féminin est sous
représenté le projet de loi contre les
séparatismes examiné à compter
d'aujourd'hui et ce pendant quinze jours
par les sénateurs à un texte
officiellement rebaptisé pour je cite
conforter le respect des principes de la
république adoptée en première lecture à
l'assemblée nationale le document
continue de faire parler
600 amendements ont été déposés
[Musique]
la france réfute toute bavure au mali et
émet des réserves sur l' enquête de
l'organisation des nations unies cette
dernière conclut qu'une frappe aérienne
menée par l'armée française en janvier a
tué 19 civils réunis pour un mariage et
pas seulement des jihadistes paris
maintient qui a un groupe armé
terroriste identifiée comme telle était
la cible
[Musique]
dix jours après la rencontre en alaska
des chefs des diplomaties américaine et
chinoise des tensions sont plus que
jamais croissante entre washington et
pékin
illustration avec la mer de chine pour
laquelle les états unis ont lancé un
vaste plan de réarmement pour contenir
la marine chinoise dont la puissance a
plus que triplé en vingt ans
[Musique]
derrière la crise sanitaire le marasme
économique et les difficultés sociétal
régulièrement évoqué la santé morale des
français plus souvent oubliée la
situation des femmes une étude de la
fondation des femmes dévoilées hier est
financé par la région ile de france
mettant en garde contre un plan de
relance privilégiant des secteurs où le
sexe féminin s'avère sous représentés
katia technique
le plan de relance at il laissé la gent
féminine de côté c'est en tout cas ce
que révèle une étude de la fondation des
femmes paru le 29 mars
bien que touché de plein fouet par la
crise sanitaire les femmes ne sont pas
soutenues par le plan de relance
économique de 100 milliards d'euros
france violence ainsi selon l'organisme
nous sommes face à un risque de
régression inédite de l'égalité femmes
hommes
l'étude restituer le contexte dans
lequel se trouvent les femmes depuis le
début de l'épidémie
le confinement de mars 2020 les a
particulièrement affecté se sont
davantage sacrifier pour la carrière de
leurs partenaires elles sont ainsi 40 %
à avoir consacré plus de quatre heures
par jour aux enfants soit le double des
hommes elles sont 21% à s'être arrêté de
travailler à cette occasion soit encore
une fois le double des hommes
le tout alors que les postes de première
ligne était particulièrement occupés par
des femmes
citons les infirmières les caissières
les agents d'entretien et j'en passe des
postes qui pour la plupart n'ont pas
fait l'objet de revalorisation salariale
des emplois souvent précaires soient les
premiers à être détruits en temps de
crise mais malheureusement personne n'a
été à leur chevet pour anticiper leurs
soucis d'emploi pendant et après la
crise du coc vide ainsi que pour
intégrer leurs spécificités à ce
programme de relance
ce plan de 100 milliards annoncés en
septembre 2020 pour assurer le retour de
la croissance
les a tout bonnement oublié malgré des
demandes des organismes concernés des
pouvoirs publics ont refusé de mettre en
place une analyse de genre et un suivi
des politiques budgétaires et de leur
impact sur les femmes
ça commence en fanfare mais voyons en
quoi consiste ce plan aveugle genre ce
sont les investissements massifs en
faveur de la transition écologique et de
la souveraineté et de la compétitivité
économique de la france les hommes sont
sur représentés dans des secteurs les
plus aisés
et qui constitue d'ailleurs une faible
part du marché de l'emploi 8 milliards
d'euros pour l'automobile 15 milliards
pour l'aéronautique 4 milliards pour les
entreprises technologiques et 8
milliards pour le secteur du bâtiment et
des travaux publics
sur les 35 milliards du plan de relance
seulement 7 milliards sont dédiés à des
emplois considérés comme féminins mais
pourtant ces secteurs ne leur sont pas
fermées il faudrait juste les soutenir
par exemple les dernières années celui
des hautes technologies a perdu 11% de
ses emplois féminins
seuls 16% de femmes sont employées dans
le secteur de la transition écologique
il n'existe pas note le rapport de
politique volontariste de féminisation
de ces emplois là rayon disques
alisation est une priorité mais l'emploi
des femmes dans l'industrie dans n'est
apparemment pas une
certes récemment le ségur de la santé a
permis de revaloriser les salaires de
nombreuses professionnels du domaine
sanitaire
mais ces augmentations n'ont pas pris en
compte les écarts de rémunération pré
existant entre les femmes et les hommes
dommage et puis il n'existe toujours
rien pour conditionner l'attribution des
fonds publics aux entreprises respectant
des règles de parité ou engageant des
actions en faveur de l'égalité hommes
femmes
la fondation des femmes proposons de
faire reculer ces inégalités
en examinant la manière dont l'accès des
femmes à l'emploi est obstruée et en
considérant aussi des données telles que
la fragilité des métiers de première
ligne ou encore les répercussions des
violences conjugales
il faudra revoir la réforme de
l'assurance-chômage adapter les
conditions du télétravail et ses
transformations suppose que toutes les
aides du plan de relance soit
conditionnée au respect de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes
il ya donc du pain sur la planche à voir
au prochain quinquennat et on dirait que
ce soir sur arte france monique dental
présidente du réseau féministe ruptures
bonsoir monnaies tantale merci de
répondre à nos questions je cite sur les
35 milliards d'euros de plans de relance
sectoriels de juin 2020 seuls 7
milliards dédiés à l'emploi occupé par
des femmes
avec ce cri d'alarmé qu'est ce que vous
attendez du gouvernement les
associations féministes dont la vôtre
est ce que vous avez déjà eu un retour
de l'exécutif par rapport à cette étude
n'ont pas encore véritablement mais il
est évident que nous sommes tout à fait
d'accord avec les conclusions de l'étude
qui a été fait par la fondation des
femmes mais peut-être qu'il faudrait
quand même préciser une chose puisque
votre reportage aborde énormément de
points mais il ya un point qui doit être
notre point de départ c'est pas dire que
un an après la fin des mii mondiale on
constate les progrès qu'ils avaient pris
en matière d'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes sont en réalité véritablement
régressé et on peut dire d'une certaine
manière que les femmes sont les victimes
collatérales de cette crise de pandémie
alors je m'attarderai pas sur les
chiffres que vous avez donnée mais
peut-être on peut quand même préciser
que par rapport à la concertation qu'a
eue le gouvernement avec un certain
nombre disons deux responsables du
territoire ou d'acteurs sociaux par
exemple les associations féministes
n'ont pas été du tout du tout entendu
alors que nous réclamons depuis un
certain nombre d'années qu'au même titre
qu'on reconnaît les syndicats ont
reconnaissent également donc les
associations notamment féministes comme
des partenaires sociétaux et après on
fait par rapport à la question que vous
me posez
on voit bien que les financements qui
ont été donnés dans le plan de relance
eh bien ces financements ils concernent
des secteurs où les hommes sont
majoritairement présente et très peu de
femmes sont présents dans ces secteurs
on sait très bien que le secteur du
digital et la transition écologique sont
occupés massivement et sur un taux plein
si demain par par les hommes donc le
coeur de ce que nous nous combattons
c'est à dire la société patriarcale pour
arriver à une plus juste égalité n'est
pas du tout mise en cause et un niveau
que le nez d'évoquer le manque de
concertation avec les associations
féministes ou avec les associations
comme vous comme vous dites des
associations il y en a beaucoup
vous avez évoqué les syndicats s'il ya
des concertations avec avec toutes les
associations avec tous les syndicats
avec tout le monde finalement on peut
pas s'en sortir c'est sans fin non pas
du tout pourquoi il faut aussi être un
petit peu moderne et de son temps c'est
à dire que les associations féminines et
féministes depuis 40 ans et même
maintenant 50 ans qu'elles existent ont
montré toutes leurs capacités avec des
forces de proposition absolument
indispensable pour répondre à une
société de moderne et à la compétition
effectivement que doit arriver a assuré
la france en tant que nation qui doit
sortir de cette crise par le haut bien
entendu surtout dans une situation de
compétitivité mondiale de l'économie néo
libérale mondialisée alors sur la
question des plans de relance pardonnez
moi on petit problème de songer pas si
vous nous entendez on a souvent dit
depuis un an que les soignants les
soignantes les pompiers les pharmaciens
les pharmaciennes les médecins étaient
en première ligne dans la crise
sanitaire
on parle en général de corps de métier
là c'est nouveau on évoque le genre
pourquoi elle est dans l'opposition
hommes femmes quant au plan de relance
dans les aides font d'ailleurs
indistinctement aux deux sexes dans un
but de relancer l'économie
ça veut dire quoi c'est l'économie elle
a pas de sexe non aussi l'économie a un
sexe
la preuve même c'est que les
institutions internationales comme par
exemple l'onu ou même l'union européenne
ont préconisé des mesures de politiques
publiques pour faire en sorte
effectivement que l'économie soit genre
et comme on dit c'est à dire qu'on
regarde l'économie
avec une approche féministe un oeil
féministes ou en mettant les lunettes du
genre si vous voulez qui permettrait
effectivement d'avoir des résultats
beaucoup plus en terme d'égalité et ça
c'est pas les associations qui veulent
qu'ils le demandent
ce sont des textes internationaux qui
doivent être appliquées par les états
par exemple l'économie genre et c'est
assez simple à c'est essayer de voir
dans tous les secteurs de l'emploi de
quelle manière on arrive à faire de
l'école de l'égalité femmes hommes et si
on n'arrive pas à la faire de prendre
des mesures
ça existe ça existe dans un certain
nombre de pays déjà par exemple comme la
suède qui est beaucoup plus loin même
que l'économie gendrey c'est-à-dire
qu'elle applique ce qu'on appelle le
gender budget thing
c'est à dire de donner des finances pour
favoriser l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes dans un certain nombre de
domaines au niveau justement de
l'économie et l'économie et les gens
mais ne serait ce que par rapport au
fait que les femmes font beaucoup plus
de travail domestique et que c'est un
travail gratuit entre guillemets ou du
secteur informel et que si on arrivait
par exemple avoir exactement la plus
value la valeur
qu'importe ce travail est bien
effectivement on serait obligé de
modifier considérablement le produit
intérieur brut des nationaux par exemple
dont
l'étude qui a été publiée hier son cité
plusieurs exemples pour prendre en
compte la spécificité des femmes par
exemple les violences conjugales les
inégalités face aux salaires etc
est ce que le plan de relance générique
de tient compte de ces disparités
est ce qu'il faudrait pas plutôt une loi
spéciale pour un meilleur accès à
l'emploi pour les femmes par exemple
dissocier les deux en gros il ya déjà
une bois en principe qui existe depuis
1984 en france et la loi de l'égalité
professionnelle
cette loi de l'égalité professionnelle
elle n'est pas appliquée donc déjà
commençons par appliquer les lois
vous savez aujourd'hui dans d'autres
sociétés il ya toutes les situations par
rapport à la question et du harcèlement
et des violences faites aux femmes ont
mis tout est un exemple frappant
justement d'un prolongement
générationnel au mouvement féministe des
années 70 qui a obtenu les droits la
contraception et à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse qu'en france
mais il y a également une très forte
demande
chez les jeunes en particulier garçons
et filles qui nous conte s'ils ne
comprennent pas pourquoi
de nos jours alors qu'ils sont très
instruits qu'ils sont capables d'exercer
toutes les professions il y a encore
entre 25 et et 13% d'inégalité de
salaire en fonction des professions donc
je crois que non seulement ce serait
appliqué la loi mais répondre à des
aspirations qui sont très très fortes
dans notre société et que la société
sera obligé de réseau parce qu'on ne
pourra pas continuer de cette manière
merci monique dental d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
la présidente du réseau féministe
ruptures
le projet de loi contre les séparatismes
est examiné au sénat à partir
d'aujourd'hui et ce pour deux semaines
de textes confortant les principes de la
république a été adopté en première
lecture par les députés mais il continue
de défrayer la chronique neutralité du
service public contrôle renforcé des
associations meilleure transparence des
cultes et de leur financement ou encore
lutte contre les certificat de virginité
ou la polygamie
beaucoup de sujets abordés alors que
plus de 600
ont été déposés présenté d'emblée
également au palais du luxembourg une
motion socialiste pour rejeter la loi on
retrouve sur place bassem chibi bassem
quelle a été la teneur des débats
aujourd'hui entre sénateurs
écoutez grégory c'est aujourd'hui que la
très contestée loi séparatisme a fait
son entrée à l'assemblée nationale après
une dès la première lecture à
l'assemblée nationale est rentré
aujourd'hui au sénat les débats ont
commencé dans les alentours 2e 15 heures
c'est les membres du gouvernement qui
ont ouvert cette session de discussions
avec le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin suivi du garde des sceaux du
ministre de l'éducation ou encore de
marlène schiappa avant de laisser la
place à différents sénateurs qui ont pu
exposer bien sûr les idées de leur
famille politique c'est un projet de loi
bien sûr qui divise la gauche qui gêne
la droite et qui arrive dans un contexte
un petit peu tendu et polémiques on vit
actuellement en france notamment
concernant les subventions qui ont été
octroyés et la construction d'une
mosquée à strasbourg par la mairie et
écologistes ou encore les propos d'
audrey pulvar la candidate ps de paris
mais également l'idée de ces réunions
non mixtes de l'unef voilà des dans quel
contexte intervient sept ce projet de
loi ici au sénat je vous rappelle qu'en
première lecture les républicains
avaient déjà voté contre ce projet ici
au sénat on est majoritairement à droite
donc les sénateurs de droite entendent
bien se positionner sur des principes
clairs bien sûr comme la lutte contre le
séparatisme
mais ils ont également annoncé qu'ils
vont intervenir sur le renforcement du
contrôle de l'instruction à domicile de
fameux article 21 qui fait polémique
alors que la gauche de son côté elle
parle d'un texte déséquilibré il
souhaite lutter contre l'islamisme
politique mais tout en évitant bien sûr
la surenchère gouvernementale je vous
propose les écouter tout la motion
préalable qui a été présenté par le
président du groupe patrick kanner qui
tend à faire la démonstration
que ce texte n'est qu'un patchwork de
mesures certaines d'ailleurs sont utiles
mais ça ne fait pas un grand texte comme
celui que nous attendrions et il fait
l'impasse sur toutes les dispositions
qui pourraient être utiles pour faire en
sorte que ceux qui s'éloignent de la
république aujourd'hui ils reviennent et
en reprennent confiance dans les grands
principes qui sont les nôtres celles
d'une république dont la devise est
liberté égalité et fraternité
moi je crois que notre volonté c'est de
réaffirmer un des principes qui fondent
notre république
bien sûr le principe de laïcité et je
crois que nous avons essayé de
l'expliquer de le faire entendre une
forme de respect encore une fois de ce
qui fait le simon de des valeurs de la
république
abbas m on l'a compris c'est un projet
de loi qui divise la classe politique
mais pas seulement la société française
c'est également des mises est
effectivement grégory ce n'est pas que
classe politique française qui est
divisée autour de ce projet de loi mais
la société tout entière successives il
également en france est divisée depuis
l'adoption en première lecture à
l'assemblée nationale de ce projet doit
les chrétiens notamment qui sont montés
au créneau et qui ont déclaré que cette
loi était discriminante et stigmatisante
les sénateurs de droite ont déclaré
qu'ils allaient tenir compte de ce
plaidoyer pour essayé d'assouplir les
obligations administratives et
comptables des associations religieuses
il y à a bien sûr aussi certaines
associations et ong qui souhaitent
défendre l'instruction a à domicile et
c'est ce qu'ils sont contre ce fameux
article 21 et bien sûr d'autres
associations antiracistes également
qu'ils souhaitent que certains points
sont beaucoup plus éclairci autour de ce
projet doit avant qu'il soit bien sûr
validée par le sénat
voilà ce qu'on pouvait dire grégory sur
cette première journée de débats autour
de cette loi c'est pas racisme ici au
sénat merci ben hassen chébili en direct
donc du palais du luxembourg à paris et
en direct dans cette édition de maurice
signolet commissaire navy
nair honoraires bonsoir maurice signolet
merci de répondre à nos questions sur rt
france on a compris élus de droite elle
est rude et i qui dénoncent un texte
manquant d'ambition le ps qui a déposé
une motion pour un retrait d'emblée trop
d'un côté pas assez de l'autre quelle
juste milieu oui je comprends je ne suis
pas parlementaire donc je me garderai
bien de rentrer dans ces polémiques deux
parties je sais que par exemple l'une
des premières volontés des groupes de
droite ou sénat ces deux de changer la
terminologie de faire de la sémantique
et de dire de lutter contre l'islam
contre l'islamisme contre le séparatisme
à ils tiennent absolument à ce mot
contre moi simplement ce que ce que je
veux simplement retenir en français
moyens et où comme un ancien policier
qu'a vécu pendant 40 ans 40 ans de
police quelques passes et je veux saluer
les initiatives du gouvernement de
proposer une telle loi mais d'un autre
côté ça démontre à quel point la
situation en france est absolument
dramatique
quand vous pensez quand on est obligé le
parlement français est aujourd'hui
obligée de débattre de la polygamie est
obligé de débattre des des certificat de
virginité de débattre des mariages
forcés
on se rend compte à quel point la
situation française est devenue
extrêmement compliqué extrêmement grave
je repensais en écoutant les
commentaires
un livre de ivan rioufol je crois qu'il
remonte à 2016 pour autant et qui avait
comme titre la guerre civile
annoncez vous voyez à quel point la
situation est vraiment extraordinaire
montant dû la droite veut réécrire le
texte vous parliez de ce mot contre
la gauche elle qui a divisé ce matin sur
public sénat le patron des sénateurs ps
patrick avec anr parlé d'un texte
déséquilibré qui l'utilisent déjà pas
les lois qui existent constat partagé
pour vous un homme de terrain
alors il est effectivement il ya des tas
de lois qui existent déjà le code pénal
réprime et des tas de textes qui sont
qui sont évoqués dans ce projet de loi
mais je vous dis là le texte même montre
bien à quel point on a une énorme
difficulté on aujourd'hui on a un énorme
problème d'intégration d'assimilation
on voit bien qu'on est obligés
aujourd'hui de parler de thèmes qu'on
n'aurait jamais abordé il ya même une
vingtaine d'années c'est surtout ça qui
est absolument est absolument renversant
quelque part c'est à ça devrait
d'ailleurs je crois que les français ne
s'y trompent pas on voit bien à quel
point la situation est devenue
aujourd'hui proches presque du tsunami
ainsi lisa sionnel ces jouets m'extraire
ainsi moi mes 40 ans de police m'ont
m'ont permis de voir cette dégradation
de la société
vous savez la police est un peu un
curseur d'appréciation de la société
aujourd'hui on n'arrête pas de dire
enfin ça fait même des années qu'on
n'arrêtait pas de dire ça va mal dans
nos banlieues on ne respecte plus
l'autorité on ne respecte plus la loi
républicaine
le mou république n'a plus aucun sens
pour certains même le mou france n'a
plus de sens pour certains donc je crois
que les les les élus les sénateurs ont
fallait parlementaires dans leur
ensemble ont tout intérêt à voir en
arrière pensée cette situation un peu
particulière que vit la france
actuellement
bassam chebbi nous nous a parlé du
contexte compliqué en ce moment
concrètement dans les faits sur le
terrain ce projet doit petit par exemple
empêcher un financement de la mosquée
strasbourg par une association qui a
refusé de signer la charte des principes
de l'islam de france
bassil
si le gouvernement retrouve l autorité
qui devrait être dans tous présents dans
tout gouvernement normalement oui on
devrait pouvoir y arriver mais il est
vrai que on va se retrouver
ne serait ce que pour l'école à domicile
ne serait ce que pour les mariages
forcés ou est-ce qu'il va falloir faire
preuve au niveau procédurales d'une
d'une acuité très particulière c'est
toutes ces dispositions législatives
vont être enfin compte
extraordinairement difficile à mettre en
application
on a parlé un de cette mosquée à
strasbourg également les réunions mixtes
à l'unef les propos polémiques d'audrey
pulvar ce cas cités tout à l'heure c'est
moche et bilan depuis le palais du
luxembourg pour pour son duplex en quoi
ce texte peut-il freiner la
fragmentation sociétal sachant que
l'intitulé même du projet de loi ne ne
parle pas de lutte contre l'islamisme on
le rappelle aussi à toutes les
fédérations du conseil français du culte
musulman n'ont pas signé la charte des
principes de l'islam de france
oui le fait même que laquelle certaines
n'auraient que les organisations
islamiques musulmane n'est pas si ce
texte se montre bien la difficulté que
l'on va rencontrer aujourd'hui alors
enfin compte
moi je vous dis je c'est l'initiative du
gouvernement d'avoir fait d'avoir
proposé cette fois parce qu'il se rend
compte qu'il ya un véritable problème
mais le problème est d'une gravité
extrême et je crois qu'il faudra dans le
futur des décisions beaucoup plus
autoritaire beaucoup plus forte
beaucoup plus à gérer presque dire plus
que culturel presque civilisationnel
parce que la situation est extrêmement
dramatique
on s'achemine quelque part moi j'ai j'ai
terminé ma carrière dans le 93
en seine saint denis on voyait bien se
développer des isolats des isolats
culturelle alors je sais bien que
d'isola est souvent caractérisée par une
langue un peu particulière par justement
une langue qui n'est pas pratiqué par
tout le monde mais là on a des isolats
qui vont se multiplier
et c'est ça la véritable difficulté je
vois comme on veut renforcer l'intégrité
de la république on n'arrête pas de
parler de république
j'ai l'impression que bientôt il va
falloir parler tout simplement de la
france il ya des endroits où bien au
delà de la république c'est la france
elle même qui disparaît c'est la france
elle même qui se délite
merci maurice signolet d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
commissaire divisionnaire honoraire à
mont de marsan dans les landes
manifestation cet après-midi d'environ
1500 agriculteurs contre une décision de
justice en cause l'annulation par le
tribunal administratif de pau de
l'unique permission de prélever de l'eau
sur le bassin d'adour ce qui va
entraîner une baisse de l'irrigation des
champs cet été les exploitants agricoles
ont notamment déversé des encombrants
devant la préfecture
entouré d'un cortège de 72 tracteurs et
remorques réaction de manifestants au
micro de charles beaudry on s'était
engagé avec nous l'état à créer des
ressources dans supplémentaires pour
affronter le changement climatique pour
avoir des productions de qualité sur le
territoire et ça on est les témoins dose
de promesses non tenues et on vient
rappeler qu'avant tout c'est nous les
premiers écolos c'est nous qui pensons à
retenir l'eau l'hiver
pour la stocker et subvenir aux besoins
de nos cultures l'été rappeler que c'est
sans eux on n'a pas deux il y aura pas
de culture y aura pas de paysans il y
aura plus de pays et que l'on vienne
défendre avant tout le citoyen et le
consommateur d'éviter les importations
on est devant les entrepôts de la
calende c'est la centrale d'achat de
leclerc du département et un peu plus
large et 1 sur la région c'est toujours
la course aux prix bas c'est toujours la
course la course au moins cher à la
concurrence avec avec leurs collègues
autres marques de gm s est en fait y'a
aucune ni aucune entente aucune
construction du prix qui peut être fait
avec eux à rester sur arte france dans
quelques instants
zoom sur la france qui réfute toute
bavure au mali et qui émet des réserves
sur l' enquête de l'organisation des
nations-unies concluons d'une frappe
aérienne menée par l'armée française en
janvier qui a tué dix neuf civils réunis
pour un mariage
puis direction la mer de chine où les
tensions sont plus que jamais croissant
d'entre eux washington et pékin les
etats-unis ont lancé un vaste plan de
réarmement pour contenir la marine
chinoise
[Musique]
gilet jaune au début ce n'était pas un
mouvement politique le peuple français
était arrivé au bout de ce qu'il pouvait
supporter il ya énormément de problèmes
en france comment se fait-il qu'on est
les impôts les plus élevés d'europe
comment se fait-il qu'on des les
déficits les plus importants
et comment se fait-il que nous dans les
campagnes on n'est même plus de service
public quand je vois l'état du pays
aujourd'hui
honnêtement j'ai mal au coeur c'est
justement tout le sens de la prochaine
élection présidentielle parce que c'est
là qu'il va falloir que les gens
apportent des réponses et moi je crois
que de toute façon on ne peut pas régler
les problèmes avec ceux qui les ont
créés et c'est impossible
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
l'actualité hervé morin c'est évidemment
la crise sanitaire ce que je défends
c'est bien sûr la territorialisation
d'injection d'épidémie à voit bien qu un
système centralisé bureaucratique tel
que celui ci a produit toute une série
de dysfonctionnements pas masquer dans
un premier temps pas de test dans un
second temps puis désormais une
insuffisance de vaccins on a senti que
vous étiez nerveux et agacé à l'encontre
de la politique de l'exécutif quant à au
déploiement de la vaccination et je
constate c'est qu'on est le 36e pays en
matière de vaccination
bon ça prouve à quel point on a un
système efficace
en normandie on aura deux usines qui
bientôt produiront des vaccins qui pour
l'un va être bientôt autorisés sur le
marché compte tenu de la faiblesse de la
vaccination je vois pas comment dans
quatre à six semaines
on pourrait se retrouver libéré
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la peuplent
c'était une volonté collective
vous le savez comme moi que dès qu'on
dit il n'y a pas d'alternative on s'en
doutait il est clair que tout le monde
attend ça est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous les libéraux l'uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes comment ces
mecs-là arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi
je pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
dignité gilet jaune c'était des valeurs
de droite c'était les gens qui
travaillent c'est des gens qui avaient
envie de transmettre quelque chose à
leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soient pas publics
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
la dignité pour tous ce que ça apporte
aux enfants
c'est une confiance confiance en soi ils
ont soif d'apprendre et izm la
connaissance mais quelque chose les
blocs aussi dans l'apprentissage à
l'école les enfants de l'ambition ils
veulent à accéder à des gros poste
veulent s'évader du quartier qu'est ce
qui ne fonctionne pas dans
l'apprentissage à l'école les
professeurs les écoles fonds nécessaires
mais je rencontre des instituteurs des
institutrices en ce1 ce2 il ya des
enfants qui ont vraiment encore du mal à
lire et écrire mais c'est pénalisant
pour l'enfant pour la famille on oublie
les parents qui sont responsables du
foyer est temps que les parents ne
maîtrise et ne parlent pas le français à
la maison basse avec difficile
[Musique]
très heureux de vous retrouver sur rt
france si vous nous rejoignez il est
21h30 heure française et l'info continue
paris pointé du doigt par l'onu en cause
une frappe aérienne de l'armée française
au mali en janvier qui a fait une
vingtaine de victimes civiles
la france réfute toute bavure elle émet
des réserves sur l' enquête de
l'organisation des nations unies le
porte parole de l'onu fait part je cite
ce soir de préoccupation très importante
julien dur ou le rapport de
l'organisation des nations unies est
accablant cette attaque aérienne a
touché la ville de bounty et coûté la
vie à 19 civils réunis pour un mariage
un constat bien éloignée de la version
française qui affirmait jusqu'ici avoir
uniquement ciblé des jihadistes l'
enquête réalisée par la mission multi
dimensionnelle intégré des nations unies
pour la stabilisation mali est formel
cette frappe n'avait rien de légal au
regard du droit international
la mine où cela est en mesure de
confirmer la tenue d'une célébration de
mariages qui a rassemblé sur le lieu de
la frappe
une centaine de civils parmi lesquels se
trouvaient cinq personnes armés membres
présumés de la katiba serma le groupe
touchés étaient très majoritairement
composées de civils qui sont des
personnes protégées contre les attaques
au regard du droit international
humanitaire
selon le rapport dix neuf personnes ont
été tuées sur le coup et trois autres
ont succombé lors de leur évacuation
parmi les vingt-deux victimes seulement
3 faisait partie de la katiba serma
organisations affiliées au groupe de
soutien à l'islam et aux musulmans
malgré les accusations le ministère
français des armées maintient sa version
le ministère français des armées
maintien avec constance et réaffirme
avec force que le 3 janvier les forces
armées françaises ont effectué une
frappe aérienne
c'est blanc un groupe armé terroriste
identifiés comme tels et aimé de
nombreuses réserves quant à la
méthodologie retenue et ne peut
considérer que ce rapport apporte une
quelconque preuve contredisant les faits
tels que décrits par les forces armées
françaises
désormais la minus ma demande aux
autorités maliennes et françaises de
diligenter une enquête qui soit je cite
indépendantes crédibles et transparentes
l'instance préconise aussi d'examiner
les processus préalable aux frappes
voire de les modifier
elle recommande également aux deux
parties d'établir les responsabilités
afin d'octroyer une réparation aux
victimes et à leurs proches
mais pour cela encore faut-il que paris
reconnaissent une bavure et en direct
dans cette édition ce soir avec nous à
mériadeck qui est raffray journaliste
spécialiste défense spécialiste
également du mali auteur notamment de l'
ouvrage à touareg la révolte des hommes
bleus aux éditions economica
bonsoir mériadec raffray merci de
répondre à nos questions ce soir sur
arte france
le rapport des nations unies conclut à
une bavure de l'armée française comment
s'est déroulée l'anc est oui j'entendais
tout à l'heure de votre dans votre sujet
un rapport accablant non il est pas
accablant une vingtaine de pages ce
rapport est épais d'une vingtaine de
pages il a été fait aux donc c'est les
faits se sont déroulés le 3 janvier nous
sommes le 30 31 mars
demain il a été fait donc rapidement
dans un contexte pour le moins confus et
compliqué d'ailleurs l'armée française
souligne qu'aucun des noms des témoins
qui ont été cités dans ce reportage n'a
été reporté dans le dans le l'enquète et
pour cause parce que les que les
conditions dans lesquelles cette enquête
se sont cette enquête s'est déroulée
sont compliquées c'est une zone
d'ailleurs qui est sous sous influence
si ce n'est sous contrôle d'une des
khatib a dû
du gsm qui est donc là la franchise 10 à
10 du nord-mali qui est affilié à al
qaïda
on sait très bien comment ça se passe et
l'argent circule ces gens là ont des
moyens de pression bref tout est
compliqué et l'enquète nom n'est pas
accablante et entre l'anc est du coup
qui n'est pas accablante
selon vos dires et la france qui croire
au final la france qui je cite a agi
avec une méthode de renseignement
robuste selon sur laon paris et c'est
pas ouais c'est pas sans me dire
ouvrez-les enquête vous verrez il n'y a
aucune
il n'y a aucune aucune manifestation de
témoin on ne sait pas qui parle on ne
sait pas d'où ces gens là parlent on ne
sait pas qui sont les témoins on est
encore une fois dans un endroit où on
fait ou là où on fait une guerre
irrégulière ou le prana le la définition
de la guerre irrégulière c'est que c'est
une guerre qui se déroule au milieu de
la population tantôt il ya des gens qui
prennent larmes les armes contre les
français tantôt ces gens là sont des
paysans sont des commerçants on a même
parlé de djihad paysans donc voyez que
la situation est très confuse
donc en fait pour l'instant on a deux
versions qui s'affrontent
on a une version qui n'a pas été qui n'a
pas changé depuis le début lorsque
l'armée française l'a donné à savoir il
est fait donc se sont déroulées le 3
l'armée française a communiqué le 7
janvier et depuis 7 janvier je constate
je constate c'est un fait c'est pas
c'est pas une prise de parti c'est un
fait je constate que la version
française n'a pas varié en revanche la
version qui a été donné d'abord par les
réseaux sociaux ensuite amplifié par sa
tombe de médias locaux cuit comme on
dirait reprise par un certain nombre de
médias français elle n'a cessé de varier
je vous donne un seul exemple au départ
les gens sur le terrain disait que
c'était une attaque qui avait eu lieu en
pendant la nuit
maintenant tout le monde reconnaît que
cette attaque s'est déroulé durant jours
on a cité on a cité un hélicoptère de
combat les hélicoptères d'attaqué
il n'y a jamais eu de l'écho perdent
attaque sur le sur la zone on a dit
qu'il y avait des femmes et des enfants
qui étaient parmi les fameuses victimes
civiles qu'ils auraient été les
comédiens et les invités d'un mariage en
maintenant tout le monde reconnaît y
compris d'ailleurs cette cette enquête
de l'onu qu'il n'y avait pas de femmes
et d'enfants parmi parmi les témoins
voilà donc en fait on efface un
professeur typique des guerres de compte
comment expliquer alors cette enquête
et je repose cette question qui croire
alors avec comme vous dites
deux versions qui sow qui s'opposent
alors moi si vous me demandez mon amour
mon analyse j'ai plutôt tendance à
croire la version de l'armée de l'armée
française le chef d'état major des
armées sur une chaîne une autre chaîne
la semaine dernière a dit devant tout le
monde je vous garantis que le droit de
la guerre et le droit des conflits armés
a été respectée dans cette opération
je vous rappelle que l'armée française
agit et lance enfin lancent des bombes
ou cible des gens lorsqu'elle a mis en
place un processus de ciblage comment ça
se passe pour les gens qui ne
connaissent pas ça c'est que à
l'état-major il y à des experts qui
regardent les dommages potentiels causés
par la cible qu'il prépare ces dommages
sont ensuite passés à l'aune du juriste
spécialiste du droit du conflit armé et
des droits de la guerre qui évalue les
les dommages et ensuite il y aura un
équilibre qui est fait et on prend une
décision en fonction de ces critères
critères qui sont également validé au
moment de l'action par les hommes qui
sont sur le terrain à savoir l'or en
l'occurrence et pilotes qui étaient dans
les avions
y compris le drone qui a survolé pendant
une demi heure et demie tout là toute la
zone et pendant l'action et donc les
tout ce qui s'est passé en fête a été
filmée donc les choses sont du point de
vue d'état major des armées relativement
clair enfin par ailleurs par ailleurs je
vous signale que ce ne serait pas la
première fois que l'onu que le nude et
les gens très des rapports dont elle
devrait ensuite comment dirais-je
s'éloigner il ya un exemple très récent
en 2014 2015
la france a été accusée par un rapport
de l'onu d'avoir quatorze aucun soldat
qui avait violé des petits enfants en
république centrafricaine le parquet de
paris a cassé la faire par un non-lieu
en disant qu'ils avaient aucune aucune
preuve donc célia il ya déjà des déjà
des antécédents de rab de rapport de
l'onu qui s'emballe un peu vite
quoi qu'il en soit l'enquète
a été fait quelles conséquences elle
pourrait avoir sur l'image des
militaires français au sahel présent on
le rappelle dans cette région sahélienne
gens vous pose cinq pays
est ce que le mal est fait aux galères
donc posé cette question en fait c'est
la question je vous ai pas entendu
monsieur est ce que le mal est fait 6
ils sont peu dire non c'est un peu un
peu réducteur mais vous avez raison de
poser cette question nous sommes dans
une guerre d'influencé une guerre
d'information est effectivement dans
cette dans cette perspective-là toute
information évidemment qui est négative
pour pour les forces françaises en
l'occurrence est évidemment un élément
qui peut influer sur les populations
mais comme toujours dansé dansé guerre
de contre-insurrection ou de lyres
insurrectionnelle les populations sont
en fait les otages des deux parties
elles sont sous la pression des
djihadistes qui s'en servent pour se
cacher et parfois même pour recruter et
elles sont évidemment l'otage entre
guillemets des forces françaises et
maliennes qui elle tente de leur
évidemment de leurs de les convertir à
la sécurité au retour de la sécurité
donc effectivement cette cette guerre de
l'information aura forcément des impacts
sur le terrain maintenant je vous
rappelle encore une fois on est là dans
une zone peu le une zone qui est sous
contrôle jihadistes ce n'est pas le cas
partout et donc il faut prendre ça avec
grande précaution y compris sur les
conséquences que ça peut avoir sur la
population malienne qui vous vous l'avez
souligné est évidemment sensibles à ce
type d'information merci mériadec
raffray d'avoir répondu à la question je
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
spécialiste défense et spécialistes
également du mali hauteur de touareg la
révolte des hommes bleus aux éditions
economica visite cette semaine d'un
diplomate américain aux îles palaos à
taïwan un déplacement rare de washington
qui a irrité pékin et ce dix jours
simplement après la rencontre en alaska
entre les ministres américain et chinois
des affaires étrangères dégradés par une
guerre commerciale débutée en 2018 les
relations entre les deux puissances sont
de plus en plus tendue je suis
illustration ces derniers jours en mer
de chine notamment hélène masculin
régler le problème chinois voilà
l'obsession des états unis depuis
quelques années alors que les relations
se crispent un peu plus chaque jour
entre pékin et washington
le premier tête à tête de leur bail
donne entre les deux pays s'est tenue en
alaska le 19 mars dans une atmosphère
glaciale
non ce n'est pas une surprise lorsque
nous avons soulevé ces questions de
façon claire et directe
nous avons reçu une réponse défensive de
la partie américaine ne devrait pas
sous-estimer la détermination de la
chine à sauvegarder sa souveraineté
nationale
sa sécurité et ses intérêts en matière
de développement ni sous-estimer la
volonté du peuple chinois de conserver
sa dignité nationale ainsi que ses
droits et intérêts légitimes
cyberattaques situation au xinjiang
taiwan hong kong
joe biden accusent la chine de menacer
la stabilité de l'ordre international
avec cette ambition prêtée à pékin
celle de remplacer les etats-unis en
tant que puissance dominante dans la
région indo pacifique et de prendre un
rôle plus important sur la scène
internationale
côté chinois il s'agit davantage de
remettre en question le leadership
mondial des etats-unis
la grande majorité des pays du monde ne
considère pas les états unis comme la
communauté internationale
les valeurs américaines comme les
valeurs internationales et la voix de
l'amérique comme l'opinion mondiale et
ils ne reconnaissent certainement pas
les règles établies par quelques pays
comme étant les règles internationales
de son côté joe biden souhaite réparer
ce qu'il considère comme les erreurs de
son prédécesseur donald trump l'ancien
président s'était retiré de l'accord de
partenariat transpacifique alliance à
même de faire rempart contre l' empire
chinois dans la zone australie inde
japon corée du sud les états unis
tentent désormais de s'assurer
partenaire précieux dans cette partie du
globe cependant certains de leurs alliés
d'asie ou d'ailleurs ne veulent pas
d'une confrontation avec la chine
je souhaiterais vivement éviter la
formation de blocs
je ne pense pas que cela rendrait
justice à de nombreuses sociétés
si nous disions que ce sont les états
unis d'un côté la chine de l'autre et si
nous faisions bloc autour de l'un des
deux selon moi ce n'est pas la façon
dont les choses doivent se faire avec sa
nouvelle route de la soie
la chine a octroyé des prêts pour des
investissements dans toute l'afrique
l'asie et l'amérique latine
en échange du soutien de ces différents
pays
la course aux investissements
internationaux pour joe biden il s'agit
aussi de rouvrir de larges avenues à l'
influence américaine
nous devons nous mettre au niveau ils
investissent des milliards de dollars
pour s'occuper d'un éventail de
questions liées au transport à
l'environnement et plein d'autres choses
nous devons nous mettre au niveau si les
deux grandes puissances ont souvent
frôlé la confrontation directe ces
derniers temps
l'interdépendance demeure élevé entre
elles en attendant c'est la diplomatie
du vaccin qui redessinent les lignes des
partenariats internationaux
pour l'heure aucune confrontation
sino-américaines de ce côté là et en
direct dans cette édition jean vincent
brisset chercheur associé à l'iris
institut des relations internationales
stratégiques
il est spécialiste de la chine
bonsoir jean vincent brisset remercier
de répondre à nos questions les
etats-unis ont lancé pour la mer de
chine
très récemment un vaste plan de
réarmement pour contenir la marine
chinoise dans la puissance a plus que
triplé en vingt ans en quoi la mer de
chine est elle si stratégique
la mère de films la première chose c'est
que c'est quelque chose que les chinois
ont décidé de s'approprier intégralement
contrairement à toutes les
réglementations internationales et la
mer de chine c'est là où passent 40 % du
trafic mondial de marchandises
donc c'est vraiment extrêmement
important pour l'ensemble de la planète
états unis et chine multiplie les
manoeuvres militaires dans cette zone
depuis plusieurs mois les adversaires se
jaugent se provoque
on cerne la rencontre et en alaska dans
tony blinken avec son homologue chinois
ça n'a rien changé sahani la nouvelle
ère by donne je pense que l'on est
vraiment sur un nouveau changement de
paradigme on a eu d'abord une époque
obama qui a constaté le problème avec la
chine c'était la première fois qu'un
président américain constate est
vraiment le problème est que la chine a
parlé de pivot vers le pacifique
et puis c'est resté au discours ensuite
on a le président trump qui lui est
parti sur un système très différent il
ya beaucoup un discours cohérent il y
avait des tas de tweets mais pas de
discours cohérent sur la politique
vis-à-vis de la chine
par contre les actions étaient
extrêmement précise et extrêmement
efficace dans le cadre d'un partenariat
bilatéral
parce que le trump ne crois pas du tout
grand match à ouvrir grandes alliances
il a récupéré le discours de trump sur
la dureté vis-à-vis de la chine mais par
contre buy donne est en train d'essayer
de revenir à des discours
multilatéraliste à des alliances à
décoder une haine contre aux patients
qui seraient pas seulement celle des
états unis
il se retrouve aussi avec des programmes
d'armement qui ont été décidées par
l'administration épreuve est entérinée
par la sienne on va voir ce que ça donne
mais là à l'heure actuelle les chinois
sont en travaux test comme le sont les
nord-coréens en 2015 la flotte chinoise
compte est de 155 bâtiments lent compte
360 360 navires de guerre aujourd'hui
soit une soixantaine de prisca l us navy
est ce qu'on peut craindre une collision
par exemple autre navire prochainement
notamment en mer de chine ce que la
situation peut basculer
alors la situation il ya un risque
effectivement alors effet le nombre de
bâtiments chinois est extrêmement
important le nombre d'équipages
opérationnel au niveau des équipages
américains est nettement moins à la
faveur de la chine
il y à il y demeure le risque dans la
mesure où il ya des bateaux qui vont se
croiser son de près en mer de chine du
sud
il ya des risques de collision des
risques de la cie dans les incidents qui
peuvent dégénérer
parce que les états unis et les marins
américains maîtrise assez bien ce genre
d'incident potentiel j'ai peur que les
équipages chinois ou pas encore le nom
maîtriser ce genre de confrontation et
pour les pays aux alentours
situé dans la zone les philippines alès
malaisie brunei au sud-vietnam aussi à
l'ouest quel danger pour ces avec ses
manoeuvres militaires
quelles conséquences notamment pour
l'industrie de la pêche par exemple les
pays sont se considèrent comme des
victimes de la chine et de
l'appropriation de la mer de chine du
sud par là par la chine de pékin
donc c'est le pays aurait tendance à
être assez content de voir apparaître
les américains on voit les philippines
par exemple qui ont craché sur les
américains pendant pas mal de temps et
qui maintenant reviennent un peu véreux
et puis des autres pays de la zone aussi
ont tendance à avoir de bons espoirs de
ricains même s'ils n'osent pas
l'affronter directement
selon l'amiral américain james stavridis
je cite pékin saic taiwan se défendra et
que les états unis pourra utiliser leurs
capacités militaires pour rendre une
opération militaire contre taïwan très
coûteuse
comment est-ce que vous analysez cette
sortie alors il faut bien se souvenir
que les états unis ont un texte qui a
valeur de loi aux états unis qui les
oblige à défendre la souveraineté de
taïwan
donc ça c'est une première chose et il
semblerait que l'administration bailon
d'adam la suite de l'administration
précédente veut bien précisé qu'il
respecte rôles envoyé allemande s'est
réjouie la vie de même et d'un autre
côté il est évident que le pouvoir
chinois qui a de grosses difficultés à
l'heure actuelle on en parle peu mais
c'est typique à une opposition interne
qu'il faudra pas mal de problèmes et des
rapports avec le reste du monde la cause
de l'épidémie en particulier il pose pas
mal de problèmes
donc tout ça ça peut conduire
tenter une opération sur le taiwan qui
pour ressouder le pays dans un élan
nationaliste et cette coopération contre
taïwan serait a priori condamné quand
même par une part des pays du monde mais
j'espère et d'aller assez loin parce que
les taiwanais qui avait une arme est
relativement faible il ya quelques
années ont maintenant une armée il sait
pas qui peut renforcer ce plan matériel
etc a surtout gagné à une force morale
et ne veut pas merci jean vincent
brisset d'avoir répondu à la question je
rappelle que vous êtes chercheur associé
à l'iris l'institut des relations
internationales stratégiques et vous
êtes spécialiste de la chine à hong kong
l'heure est à la préparation des
élections législatives pour l'occasion
de la chine a approuvé aujourd'hui une
réforme du système électoral du
territoire désormais les candidats
devront être validés par un comité
chinois avant de se présenter le pays
dit vouloir je cite assurer la stabilité
et la prospérité de la région
administrative cyrielle benavides prêt
payant à l'unanimité les 167 membres du
comité permanent du parlement chinois
ont voté ce mardi une réforme du système
électoral hong kong est une décision
unilatérale puisque le parlement au
congrès lui même n'a pas participé au
vote
les modifications des amendements 1 et 2
ont déjà été promulguée par chip jean
ping et vont entraîner davantage de
députés
le nombre de députés au conseil
législatif le l'écho passe donc de 70 à
90 avec une réduction du suffrage
universel direct
plus que vingt sièges seront pourvus de
manière démocratique contre 35 avant la
réforme 40 sièges seront désignés par un
comité de personnalités favorables au
gouvernement chinois et les 30 derniers
sièges seront laissés au choix deux
groupes socioprofessionnels une
technique déjà à l'oeuvre dans la région
et qui a toujours été favorable à pékin
désormais les citoyens hong kong et
n'éliront plus que 22 % de leurs députés
autre modification plus radicale la
création d'un comité de contrôle qui
devra évaluer le niveau de patriotisme
des candidats
sans oublier un avis de la police de
hong kong qui devra stipuler que ces
mêmes candidats ne présente pas de
risque pour la sécurité nationale
leurs décisions seront sans appel si
l'opposition comptait sur ces élections
pour obtenir davantage de sièges au
parlement
ces espoirs s'estompe avec l'entrée en
vigueur de cette réforme dès mercredi
quant à karine ham chef de l'exécutif
local
elle se veut rassurante route l'entente
pour améliorer le système électoral de
la région administrative spéciale de
hong kong vise à s'assurer que ce sont
les patriotes qui administrons congrès à
propos
ils doivent se conformer à une exigence
qui figure dans nos lois électorales à
savoir prêté allégeance à la région de
hong kong ce qui est l'objectif de cette
réforme pour les gens qui ont des
convictions politiques différentes qui
sont enclins à plus de démocratie qui
sont plus conservateurs qui
appartiennent à la gauche ou qui
appartiennent à la droite
tant qu'ils répondent à cette exigence
fondamentale je ne vois pas pourquoi il
ne pourrait pas se présenter aux
élections
grâce à cette réforme pékin renforce une
nouvelle fois son influence au sein du
territoire semi-autonome une entrave
selon les britanniques au principe un
pays deux systèmes en ukraine à moscou
pointe du doigt une escalade des
tensions le porte parole du kremlin la
firme les choses vont mal et tensions
politiques n'ont toujours pas été réglés
le processus de paix entre forces
ukrainienne rebelles de l'est du pays et
je cite dans l'impasse la correspondance
en russie dans ton nucléaire ou durant
toute la seconde partie de l'année 2020
le cessez-le-feu en vigueur dans le
donbass était globalement respecté mais
la région connaît ces trois derniers
mois une escalade des tensions sur la
ligne de contact
et la tendance n'est pas franchement à
l'optimisme le porte parole du kremlin
constate que les modestes réalisations
accomplis jusque là ont été réduites à
néant
au début du mois de mars le président du
conseil européen en tenait la russie
pour responsable et estimé qu'elle ne
tenait pas ses engagements engagements
qui sont pourtant écrit noir sur blanc
dans les accords de minsk la seule
feuille de route reconnu par toutes les
parties prenantes au conflit
comme le rappelle dimitri peskov reuters
marc rich
il ne faut rien compliqué il faut tout
simplement examiné et relire ce document
pour constater que malheureusement kiev
ne les a pas appliquée en outre un
document a été signé à l'issue des
négociations qui ont eu lieu à paris il
en va de même la plupart des accords
n'ont pas été mises en oeuvre
voilà ce qui a été dit en réponse à la
question du journaliste à cet égard
pourquoi l'autre partie ne respecte t
elle pas les dix accords c'est une
question qui doit être adressée à la
partie ukrainienne l'ukraine à la russie
continue donc de se rejeter la
responsabilité de la non application des
accords de minsk et c'est la population
du dombass qui en paye le prix
la population rendus plus vulnérables
encore par la crise sanitaire
la pandémie de co vide qui a entre
autres fait passer au second plan ce
conflit qui dure depuis bientôt sept ans
assise à la fin de cette émission
prochain point sur l'actualité dans
quelques minutes on se retrouve tout de
suite resté sur rt france
[Musique]
la gauche aujourd'hui